welcome h3 warriors today we go to war
who what do we go to war against what
are we going to war my cursor is a micro
transaction in video games video oh
we're going to war against me no no
micro transactions in vain' ok and
youtube you had mentioned I'm so mad
right now today we go to war over
microtransactions and and youtube and
thank you - stamps calm and me undies
our guest today if you couldn't tell is
the wonderful boogie2988 a lot of people
may not be able to tell because I look
like a complete in person I mean besides
losing now 250 pounds mm-hmm 150 since
the surgery then I got the brand new
teeth hi
which is really weird because I'm still
getting used to this this is three weeks
I've had these teeth and and I don't
know I change frames and it was like you
look like a hipster now I'm like I just
trying to look like GAMEOVER Greggy if
the depression finally one for game over
Greg I want to look like Greg Miller as
if like he just gave up that's what I
was looking for work well you really
have transformed and I love that you
regularly come and check in with us
because yeah from the first time this is
your third time on the show now I'm the
finally three timers you have I'm like
oh actually you may be the first three
time well thank you happy yeah I mean I
love having you you're one of the best
guess ever yeah for the first time you
came in here you were with your now
ex-wife hmm and you could not enter
unassisted right you were I remember you
want such excruciating pain
I just might honestly it felt so
horrible for you like just seeing you go
down I wasn't trying to go out you had
to exit and take a break now - now
looking at you you told me you were just
walking around Universal for like five
miles a universal another mile around
Hollywood that night and so six miles in
a day and a little sore from it have
some blisters well I would be telling ya
I realized at home by the way you're
dealing with my now
Lisp it's temporary mighty I'm just
getting used to my new teeth I'm only
three weeks out so if you can tell my
voice has changed a little bit it's
going to get better if I don't really
notice that much but I understand you
it's probably more noticeably conscience
but you just got new brand new teeth
three weeks ago
why did you need T I mean I know why did
you need new teeth what did they pull
all your teeth out like he tell me it's
over like hereditarily my family has the
worst teeth and my mom and my dad
wearing dentures by 40 and I probably
needed to be in dentures by 40
my brother has struggled us alive for
the implants to stop my sister has very
like she lost all her teeth and had to
get stuff early on in their 20s so I had
just had this fatalistic attitude about
my teeth one day I will get dentures and
not just won't worry about it and I
definitely didn't record you don't have
dentures you have like no these are my
employee that's the real deal
g4 buy gulp accom are the people that
did it and they have like a cutting-edge
technology they call the the the g4
system and basically they they screw
metal posts they pulled all my teeth
only at 17 teeth left I don't know how
many - oh wow that's 14 were infected I
was walking around 14 rampant infections
of your mouth he's saying all the time
all the day after surgery I was in less
pain than I was the day before and
that's after them cutting me wide open
right so they remove all the teeth and
they cut open the gums and they go in
and they they shape the bone and then
they put in metal posts and I'm like
half conscious during all this like I if
you watch the video on my youtube
channel youtube.com slash Brookings
donate typing boogie teeth and you'll
see this video even show where they
spliced me open just put in the metal
teeth but I was so awake they're like
give me a thumbs up and I'm like because
I was conscious but I don't remember it
why don't they keep you conscious they
wanted to make sure that I could answer
commands and stuff when we need to open
her mouth we need you know we need you
to set up they need you to be a new
writer but they also give you like a
twilight drug so you don't have to
remember any of it so I don't and it
gave me some painkillers too obviously
right now
yeah but they put in these metal posts
yeah that skull screw in your skull and
then screw into your jawbone and then
they put bridges that are then screwed
onto those metal screws and I can I can
go to them and they'll take these out
and they can clean them and I have to do
that at least once a year and ordeal
they don't take them out yeah just one
screw up and and I can't do it at home
right because it's the special tools and
stuff but at the bridge you ever broke
or anything and so a lot of people
realize this
the guns the gums look hella healthy and
their prosthetic as well yeah look at
that natural right but if you really
really seein you can see where they need
my actual guns right closely I can't
yeah I feel like I mean the internet
seems to keep telling me that the upper
row is a little too big but I like them
right that what do they mean the top
like maybe the top two teeth are a
little too big for my face or something
but I like it and so this is one of
those instances where the Internet has
been kind of mean a lot of people mostly
supportive right some people are like oh
you look like spongebob and that one
episode or you look like the guy from
the two fairy godmothers or what here's
the [ __ ] you okay no one [ __ ] you all
right I didn't do this for you I don't
care if you like it I do this for me I
wanted to get out of pain I wanted to
get out of infection I wanted to look a
little better sure I'm human I don't
really care how I look but I care about
not hurting all the time and the other
reason I did is because the company
that's doing this they agreed to give
away to people who are in need of for
real 12 surgeries over the next year so
they just announced that if you go to g4
by global com
I think it's like a sub site I'm not
sure it's linked on the web main website
but if you search for it they want
people to submit like stories and videos
and pictures and they let me pick 12
people and do the surgery it really
really light and what he changed it for
me right
it's like it's a life-changing thing
right and it's unbelievable well I told
them if somebody comes in and mentions
my name I want to talk every person that
comes into my sister's name right so we
had the first person come in that
mentioned seeing my video and I've been
like texting him back and forth then he
got his teeth two days ago and like just
coaching him through it and like the
healing procedure and because my healing
procedure was atypical because I'm a
youtuber and I know that sounds weird
you mean because you have to show your
mouth well not only that but because I
they told me go home and talk as much as
you need to because you're gonna need to
learn how to speak and eat soft foods
for the first couple of weeks but you
can eat some rougher stuff you're gonna
be fine like you salad don't worry about
it be some broccoli you'll be fine avoid
nuts for now right and
a week after the surgery I started
bleeding hmm I was doing a pique
woodysgamertag his podcast and I started
bleeding and so I called my doctor and
I'm like doc what's happening it goes
you maybe you've ruptured one of the
stitches have you been eating a lot I'm
like doc I'm a fat guy yes I've been
eating a lot of eating soft foods
because like are you talking a lot and
I'm like no I'm barely talking I did a
four hour podcast today filmed a YouTube
video that took of our talking and then
I screamed on my twitch channel for
three hours
I barely talked for eight hours today
and he's like shut the [ __ ] up
and sat down because you're you're
causing your mouth to bleed because no
one talks for eight hours what are you
doing why are you doing this what's my
job
and so uh I bled for like three days
straight like just like like a little
bit it was like a lot when it's coming
out of your mouth because it mixes a
salon yeah
and so like on the third day I messaged
him and I'm like hey doc I've been
bleeding for three days should I be
worried he's like Steve half the
population bleeds for three days woman
up okay so you're gonna be fine
right oh my god woman up yeah he's a
woman of because half the population
literally bleeds for three kind of week
here huh
yeah but I think if woman were bleeding
from the mouth they'd be more concerned
too you know I always worry about a lot
blood loss and everything else but he's
like no you're fine
he is is a lot he's got patients
bleeding up from their mouths he's like
well no no baby he said it's the only
time that's ever happened
that's exactly time anybody has talked
himself out of huh out of the recovery
you know how much does that that
procedure cost
he's expensive yeah gaveling Medicare it
can I think it comes in like eleven
thousand my surgery would have been
thirty eight thousand thirty thousand
that is restrict right but I mean it's
so good it's so life-changing what man
that's it's implants for like five
thousand dollars a tooth and so if you
need 32 teeth replace like oh that's way
more expensive like it's a hundred and
fifty thousand or something yeah this
procedure is cutting-edge it's been done
like ten thousand times I think now he's
done it and there's like the all on
system and then there's the g4 system
what's like what's cutting-edge about it
like
it's a much faster turnaround it's
easier and a lot less expensive than the
other options and so I was really
surprised really glad to do it but the
reason I did is because Jake the snake
Roberts I've talked to him like once
Diamond Dallas Page mean him or friends
and Jake got the procedure done and it
went viral and like a lot of you know I
so that's why I reached out of the
company I'm like please help me I will
proselytize I will go on the h3 podcast
and will tell everybody that's listening
there that you guys offer this service
because I know there's a lot of people
other but when they agreed to do it for
like 12 other people how do you not do
it for even if I didn't want to do it at
that point I we can do it I don't want
some new origin record you know that
there's people in Hollywood and I and
I'm almost sure this is true who have
teeth like mine that are fine but not
like extraordinarily beautiful or
anything and they'll get these
[ __ ] yanked and gets beautiful
brand new teeth in or veneers I was
talking to you I swear bro there why is
it that everyone probably is walking
through it unless you needed to
medically because you have like
beautiful perfect one procedure for sure
um it was far it was not great the first
24 hours it's not great the first week
was not great but after the first week I
was in less far less pain than I was any
other point with my teeth problems bro
do you think that getting fake titties
is pleasant they do they get fake asses
Kim Kardashian has like two cabbages in
her an ass right the Abbi do you have
you seen I'm telling you like I guess I
just we gotta find pictures of like
celebrities with like ridiculously
perfect teeth you can almost tell when
their faith I always wonder Jim Carrey
Steve or fake cuz there Jim Carrey
listen come up you ought to bring up you
ought to bring up a before picture of my
teeth because there's a hug they're so
bad looks like the broken picket fence
around my gym bag this cord of uh it's
got some pictures of some
celebs that have done it yeah oh we got
celebs they've done it this is what I'm
into this is what and you're right I
mean the second one down is Hilary Duff
and they have before and after well
we're fine really
what
I don't know what's going on no that's
not real scroll down one though [ __ ]
down the second one is very obvious the
Duff yeah bro well you know I'm not
convinced about that one either here's
that here's what I will tell you people
treat you different when you do this
Israel I'm so weird the Clooney but then
you can kind of see like what is going
on like did you see what I'm saying you
look like white what is with these
beautiful perfect teeth that they have
like I know it so Americans are obsessed
they are okay get a load of this I think
that's why I'm so shocked that anyone
would do it unless they had to like
medically well think about when I think
about this it's normal to put braces on
kids because there's teeth need to be
straightened for right I mean that's so
straight-up cosmetic surgery right it's
crazy but you'd like you just said
people treat on the way back well yeah
from surgery I noticed for the first
time I was going through the airport and
every time I've ever gone to like the
airport the girl behind the counter does
this she's like hello sir mmhmm yeah are
you going you have your ID and the very
first person I interacted with after
surgery she's like hi sir how are you
today yes do you have your ID like
direct and high contact the whole time
and I stopped to get a sandwich and the
guy behind the counter is like hi how
are you they surfing I'm like are people
really the shallow does it make no I
don't give I don't think it's shallow I
think that you almost you just wanted to
avert your gaze because you don't want
to stare or be rude or something I think
I don't think that it's like oh he's so
hideous I can't look at him right I just
think that it's like because I do that
saying I do that same thing with
attractive people to I'm like I have to
stare directly in your eyes and because
I don't want to look at those delicious
man boobs you have that right back yeah
but what do you mean that's a cosmetic
surgery absolutely yeah but do you see
what I'm saying like it does make a diff
like she's got these celebrities they
have to be perfect right right they got
the fake ass they got the fake tits
let's get some fake teeth in there too
I guess if it'd make you if it makes you
feel better about yourself I'm not one
to judge but wait this is a love song if
it makes you happy look at that
beautiful day yeah you're an exclusive
club now bugs oh hell yeah Chris Rock
look I'm telling you his teeth are great
before but there's there's a bunch of
gaps yeah thank you God adds personality
I agree but they disagree with you her
chill my other mother fYI they get
wooden teeth back in look perfect now
friend of the show yeah he's a friend so
there you have it I'm telling you I love
this man 50 cent look at that beautiful
smile oh that's a smart call but like
some people get just veneers as well
right like you're right Jim Carrey
apparently Oh a chipped tooth come on
get out of here with this yeah yeah look
at that beautiful teeth oh that's
perfect right yeah I didn't want mine to
be - okay so I asked for one dollar
please I didn't wanted to be perfectly
even you know ya know I feel you can't
go right I don't want to be greedy all
right so I want I ask for longer canines
and I jokingly said can I get vampire
teeth and it's like yeah I like what
he's like I didn't get them it looks
normal but he's like if you want if you
want weird teeth you come back in here
with some money we'll make whatever
crazy people you want we don't care yeah
if I was you're gonna be like trust me
you do not that one like giant werewolf
bring teeth or something I don't know I
go like get a guerrilla I guess I can
make me a grill now sure except it
wouldn't be a grill over these
prosthetic teeth we have a grill man
that's crazy
what is the maintenance like it's a pain
in the ass so number one obviously this
is my teeth were rotting out I didn't
have a very good maintenance routine I
did mouthwash twice a day and I was done
brush ya know cuz it hurt the brush I
was painful it was excruciating I would
bleed every time I tried to brush you
know I had like 17 toughen tanned teeth
anyway but like can you imagine when you
have an infection taking a toothbrush
over it is miserable so just hit
mouthwash two or three times a day now
I've got a brush after every meal I have
to
my mouth out with mouthwash after every
meal I have to floss but you don't floss
between the teeth because there is no
gap between these people the gap is
between the gums and the bridge I have
to start off with water pick that make
sure there's nothing under there and
then I have to take those right and
actually I'm not flossing the bridge I'm
flossing the metal posts those metal
posts built there's market I was
wondering there's no gap yeah yeah it's
pain in the ass yeah that's pretty
intense yeah it's a pain in the ass but
it's worth it
I mean once you have to keep this nice
I'm gonna take care of for the rest of
my life I'm so excited to have them
right yeah I had nice teeth growing up I
might have taken care of them mm-hm
but it's been it's been really weird
like like you mentioned the the start of
the podcast the ability to walk this
morning I woke up and had another crater
one of the bright a lunch before I came
to the show I'm like okay where do you
want to meet so we walked for two and a
half blocks and I didn't think about it
and I'm like sore I had blisters on my
feet from universal yeah but yeah it's
it's it's very freeing because I had to
do right after the show last year I had
to do physical therapy mmm
and there I think maybe just before
actually and they they were telling me
you have to learn how to walk again
you're still walking like a 600 pound
got your swaddling right we have to
teach you everything how to walk how to
sit how to be in your new body mm-hmm
and now that I've done that I've gone
cave exploring a couple times I've hiked
the mountain in Colorado I only made it
like halfway up I might like two miles
up but still be able to do that and I
think I can make it at the top of that
mountain now it's just I know it's very
freeing yeah I can imagine I mean it's
fascinating because I I feel like
there's obviously the first time I came
here I felt like I was gonna die like
that right I never thought I would dig
Muro I didn't think you had long to live
I mean you were you did not I mean man
you you couldn't even make it down the
stairs you had to sit down and catch
your breath oh that's very dimensional
yeah I really was I was in so much pain
that too because we're doing VidCon and
we were traveling and I injured my back
a little bit that day so I remember you
told me you were on the ground just in
pain you could do your back bones so bad
and so as your pain in your joints in
your back and everything getting my
teeth out maybe
huge difference for my back pain I can't
believe it but he's like oh I'm a
constantly uh
college and it's all connected right and
so I was out of like a for everyday when
I woke up before the teep getting taken
out three weeks ago now three weeks
later I'm at a one when I wake up I'm
not even taking my pain medication right
I'm credible I'm just like I just get up
and move
it's I can't congratulate yeah yeah
that's a beautiful so I'm curious to see
where I'm gonna be this time that's here
the Internet is convinced I'm not gonna
get fat again
yeah and like I'm gonna reverse the
process but I I'm so motivated by not do
that because life is yet Internet is
truly a collection of the very most I li
yeah yeah you're not right you're not
running like I don't know it's like
George Carlin said I don't insult any
viewers out there obviously right go
ahead in Salt Lake George do it George
Carlin once said think of someone you
know of average intelligence and not
average intelligence for your sprint
circle with actual average nouns and
then remember half the world's dumber
than that [ __ ] yeah that's a
great loss like I think there's a lot of
smart people out there who are purposely
obtuse and purposely but they don't
listen to this show right of course the
only the smart most but I will say some
of those idiots see clips from the show
and they're like let's use this as a
weapon you know let's take a quick break
when I come back I want to talk about
the blowback you got from the last time
he came oh yeah that was fairly you had
some you had some issues I didn't really
follow it I had a great time I thought I
was I just thought it was one of the
best and I went off and did the rest of
VidCon and then I made the mistake of
checking Twitter at one point I was like
oh my guy like death threats had people
like calling for my blood the end of my
career I'm like okay well let's get into
that
I'm curious cuz I don't know what you
said so let's take a quick break guys
we'll be right back and we will find out
why there's a bounty on know they're
looking right there probably is yeah the
man no no let's be right back
no one's got time to go to the post
office you're busy I'm busy we're all
busy okay the post office is a pain in
the butt that's why you need stamps calm
the most popular time-saving tool for
small businesses and individuals that
just liked us and stuff in the mail Sam
saw comm eliminates trips to the post
office and saves you time and money with
discounts that you couldn't even get at
the post office
stamps comm brings all the amazing
services of the u.s. post office right
to your computer whether your small
office sending invoices or an online
sellers shipping out products or just a
sweet young grandchild who's sending
birthday cards to his grandma even a
warehouse sending thousands of packages
a day
stamps.com can handle it with ease
simply use your computer to print
official US postage 24/7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send once your mail is ready
you just hand it to your mail carrier or
drop it in a mailbox it's really that
simple
with Sam's comm you get five cents off
every first-class stamp at up to 40% off
Priority Mail not to mention it's a
fraction of the cost of those expensive
postage meters I don't know what postage
Mainers are but I guess if you're
someone who knows what it is you know
what it is
Sam's do you know what I mean like you
either know where you don't Sam comm is
a no-brainer saving you time and money
it's no wonder over 700,000 small
businesses or to use stamps comm listen
to this offer this is a good one right
now our listeners get a special offer
that includes a four week trial plus
free postage and a digital scale without
any long-term commitment free postage
just like free money go to stamps calm
that's literally free money you know you
can buy [ __ ] with stamps they say it's
legally money is that right then let's
go stand I don't don't try that but
something I've heard go to stamps calm
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type h3 that stamps
comm go to the microphone enter h3 if
you want some free postage scales the
whole shebang convenience everything
Samsung Co did you
that you spent did you know that the
average person spends 90% of their life
and underwear no my case a hundred
percent because I have a phobia and I
don't like taking my dick out ever like
when me and when we conceived I was
wearing boxers but just get took it out
of the hole right so in my case a
hundred percent and then so that means
it's really important that I'm in the
most comfortable underwear that I could
possibly find on the market that's why I
like to introduce you guys to me undies
it's made of micro modal it's soft as
hell it's breathable it's gonna change
your life because a lot of us walk
around these cheap package underwear
that's chafing it's an it's a all over
the place you have too much freedom
let's say in some cases you have not
enough that's what me undies innovates
it's soft its flexible its breathable it
has it all you didn't know that
underwear could be this comfortable
until you put it's in size give it a
shot you got nothing to lose here okay
it's so soft
it's three times softer than cotton
you're gonna feel like you're being
hugged by joy itself and you got
multiple styles for women men and women
making out try new boxer briefs with a
fly what an innovation which is some of
the great cut as boxer briefs now and
added option for guys who prefer to go
through the gate first over the fence
that way there's a third option that
many people don't know about you can go
down the leg hole just a third option
the tunnel down the tunnel through the
tunnel sure the man DS is also go-to for
the softest loungewear on the planet
hang out in their supply comfy lounge
pants and onesies yes man these makes
onesies and they're incredible so here's
where basically you've nothing to lose
mandis has a great offer for my
listeners for any first-time purchaser
when you get any my undies you get 15%
off and free shipping get 50% off a pair
of the most comfortable undies you will
ever put on and there's a hundred
percent satisfaction guaranteed so if
you don't like it boom send it back they
don't Center in it they're burn it and
you get your money back so it's a
goddamn we went 15% off your first pair
of free shipping 100% satisfaction
guaranteed go to Mandy's comm /h tree
that's me Andy's calm
/h of the
welcome back we are here with year boy a
boogie and we've got the tensions
explained so you're in the hot seat now
I destroy my career on this part yes so
used to say that but obviously you're
here you're back you're good good go I
love your aunties no but you didn't
really destroy I know if can feel like
that I'll plan we've all kind of we've
all kind of felt that times but do you
really think that you nearly destroyed
your career last time you're on here um
well and specifically what topic okay so
we were talking about like the lbgtq
community and I said something very
stupid I don't want to repeat what I
said cuz it was really stupid
um okay I don't remember what you said
no it was I was talking about like
same-sex marriage and how the Supreme
Court ratified it really quickly and how
the world like reacted very poorly to
that and I my intention was to say that
I I hate that people are getting killed
over the [ __ ] and I wish that we had a
way for people not get killed the way I
said it was very stupid basically but
that was my intention I don't I hate
that people are killing each other in
the streets and I just don't want that
to happen
right and because that people took it
out of context and they ignored the
intention and then it was it was
miserable so okay so it was just that
one statement about and that's right
what's the big one that was the biggest
I thought it was about like something
else cuz that I didn't we were talking
about all kinds of wonderful things like
feeder
you had a expression that I was on the
show yeah if I'm being honest I was in a
complete mental breakdown I was in the
middle of a complete mental breakdown
the last year of my life last two years
of my life since the gastric bypass
surgery almost two years ago has been
both the best year of my life because of
my recovery and the worst year of my
life because of the changes I've gone
through and the negative and attention
I'm getting on the Internet and like who
gets here's a story they gave you an
example of how rough my life has been I
don't want to play the victim or
anything like that but my ex-wife and I
agreed to separate two months after my
gastric bypass surgery right and we
didn't make it public until like four
months after my gastric bypass surgery
so I go to the one-year meeting with my
surgeon who did my gastric bypass
and I'm depressed because I started off
at 550 ish right
my biggest error was 587 I go into the
office and I'm like 380 mmm at the
one-year mark and now I'm like 340 but
at 380 I felt defeated because I
expected to do so much more till a lot
of it was right 117 what did you expect
I mean what did I want it to be well
that's the thing so I tell the doctor
how frustrated I am how mad I am
and he's like Steve I want to show you a
chart and he pulls out of Chardon he
says you've lost 50% of your excess body
weight mm-hmm at the one-year mark
now that the here's your chart here's
where you charted here is the national
average for people get the surgery
you're exactly on cue you have lost
exactly 50 percent of your excess body
weight after one year that's what
everybody does your average and I'm like
but I didn't want to be average done
yeah I wanted to be exceptional I've got
a lot of people watching a lot of people
counting on me and I wanted to do better
and he goes but do you don't have any
idea how many of my patients go through
a divorce in the first three months of a
Hesus if I'm being entirely honest with
you we watched your videos in the
audience in the office and when you
announced that you were getting divorced
we didn't think you were gonna lose any
more weight we thought you were gonna
stop it like four thirty four twenty mmm
now here you are 380 and you're still
losing yeah and the window hasn't closed
you still have plenty of chances to lose
weight you are the exception I've never
had a patient go through a we have
plenty of divorces because it's very
common with this procedure but never two
months after the surgery that's never
happened Plus lest you are here you
spoke very highly of your ex-wife and I
still will you guys are very honorable
we're still friends I've talked to her
most of the time I've been here we've
been trading pictures back and forth
we're still friendly just really the
timing though yeah we just we didn't
worse when we we just yeah and we just
didn't work and she had things that she
wanted to go do and things that I needed
to go do and God loved her here's the
thing she could have easily left before
that surgery and I would have never
gotten it she would have been leaving me
for dead she stuck around through the
surgery she stuck around through the
recovery I wasn't fully recovered but I
stop bleeding for the most part I I was
able to take some care of myself she
left me in good hands with my best
friend of my roommate you know and he
stayed like an extra month after we
agreed to separate just to make sure I
was okay right that is very nice she
said she's a good person I'm still you
know I probably the love of my life
honestly I don't know that I'll ever
love anybody the way I loved her and and
Dom's like you still have when you say
that that makes me wonder if you see
down the road some kind of
reconciliation or relation if I'm being
entirely brutally honest and I feel no
reason not to you know this is one of
those moments where my brains like don't
say it but I'm gonna say it if I'm
entirely brutally honest we didn't work
and we weren't happy and I don't see us
ever working because we just don't have
the matching personality types and she
said something to me on the way out the
door that I'll never forget she's like I
told her I'm like I'll never get
remarried after this and she's like
you're already married and I'm like I
know but we're getting a divorce because
that's not I'm talking about you're
married to this job she's cool it's all
you do even when you couldn't do
anything else you're in front of this
computer 12 hours a day working on
YouTube working on streaming working on
phone calls working on brand deals it's
all you do isn't that a little unfair
though because I mean that is how you
guys met right well yeah we met through
YouTube yeah but she's not wrong right I
mean you know and so that's been my
focus in the last year I started dating
I talked about last time I was on the
show I started dating and doing the
whole youtuber thing like hey I've got
money and hey I'm kind of famous and hey
I can meet a lot of girls and then that
got really boring after like six months
or so and it went wrong a few times I'm
like I met a lot of robbery unsavory
people like girls who would like who are
in it for the money I like asked for
money right would they ask you for like
hey can you help me with rent and here's
the kinda look for hunter bucks for run
Oh for real all right I'm like no like
of course not like this is where this is
not prostitution we're we're dating
right a good dealer process right that's
a good deal yeah especially some of the
girls that I got to go out but
eventually I realized that I don't think
I'm meeting anybody with good intentions
any time soon fare and then don't get
wrong if you're a sugar baby out there
if you're a gold digger you're a sex
worker I got nothing but love and
respect for you she's not something that
I necessarily need a mile
for the time yeah right now right you
you need you need emotional you need
nurturing bingo right and so you know
that's what I was looking for is an
emotional relationship not a physical
one it was nice having a physical
relationship I didn't get to do that in
college so it was nice to do that post
divorce but now I guess eight months of
just not really looking or not you
haven't been romantically involved or I
really I've had a few dates just like
hey do you want to go see in game with
me all right let's go same game yeah you
know or let's let's you I like you to
ruse Chris you're cute do you want to
eat a roost Chris tonight and then
sometimes we make it back to my house
and sometimes we don't
it's mostly just about the experience
and sharing with somebody pretty but
never am I I'm not even considering an
emotional relationship because I want to
work on my business and I want to work
on my body and when I get to the weight
that I'm at when I get the way that I
want to look when I've got the money in
the bank that I want to have then I'll
start looking for somebody and as it is
right now it's just making how much
money do you need in a bank to get it
took you know you look it you don't got
to pull off so much I want a theorem to
go through the roof because once I have
fuck-you money
now I'm still gonna do YouTube it's
going to do it difference so what are
y'all friends let us you money in your
mind I would like to have I'd like to
have a solid cleared one point five
million and I'm not tied up into my
house not tied up in the cars and I'll
tie it up into anything else I have one
point five million dollars liquid that I
can invest and put wherever I want it
make me more money when I have that kind
of money I will be so Arkansas rich I'll
never tell anybody in the state except
the Waltons of course right
Arkansas rich I love that yeah 1.5
million doesn't get you very far
no it does not but in Arkansas it gets
you off like ten houses because I bought
my dream home there for like a quarter
million and then they're in the divorce
we had to change ownership and
everything so we had to get reevaluated
and I got to re-evaluate at 310 I've
owned it for years so my house it was
like 270 is what we bought it for
announced for 310 yeah so I bless for a
right what are you making money yeah
living in it my mortgage is only 1500
1500 month yeah off of a 15-year
mortgage
yeah
saying yeah that's really good so III
think eventually I'm just gonna become a
well I think he's more out there and buy
all the house yeah absolutely
thrown like a block and this is my
blocking this absolutely set up
centuries and barbed wire fence right
powered events real-life tower fence
right
be ready with Amin but that's the that's
the thing when it when I get to that
point it's just gonna the only thing I'm
really change I think I would I want to
do YouTube yeah I would have thought
that you would have already had some
more close to that already well I did
get divorced yeah you know that you lose
half yeah right but a lot of people
always think I made one even I did but
you remember YouTube at the beginning
the view numbers were low even though
the pay was I right yeah and I've only
ever I'm still working on my billionth
of view I still haven't had my billion
view tube even right and had revenue for
me I've always been on Adsense I've
never been with an MCN so I've always
had the lowest possible ad rates off of
Adsense and then I've never been really
brand friendly on top of that because
the Francis video isn't breaking stuff
and destroying stuff and smashing stuff
so it's been hard to get brains to work
with and I've really changed that in the
last three years yeah but most of the
money that was offered to me would be
video game companies right mmm and hey
let's fly you out and we'll give you
some money review our game I'm not
taking money to review a game on what
planet well then don't review it just
talk about it okay but that's a lie
right well I did that once really I
actually did that once with the Ubisoft
game ooh
Ubisoft well I have for it was a
Assassin's Creed the one that had
multiplayer and right and they like
booked the flights we booked the tickets
we booked the hotel and we want you to
come out and play it and so they had two
rounds of influencer showing up and one
of my friends showed up for the first
round your phone sorry I'm sorry buggy
following issues here I swear to God I
viewed it [ __ ] unbelievable or slap you
right in the Fupa yeah no but
Ubisoft the the Assassin's Creed game
with the multiplayer in it even they
booked the tickets the the booked the
flights that booked the hotel the whole
nine yards I pay you
yeah a little bit like spending money
okay and just just a cover of meals and
[ __ ] right yeah and so I'm ready to go
out and play the game and experience it
and they want
you give an honest review right but I
don't know how I feel about flying out
to play a game now I do because I just
trashed Mortal Kombat 11 for its
microtransactions even though they flew
me out for the reveal for that right but
at the time I was new and I was nervous
and I didn't know how it feel about
trashing a game I got a trip for right
yeah so they had two rounds of
influencers and my friend did the first
round and she calls me and she's like do
not show up and like watch you guys it's
a [ __ ] show hmm it's miserable
III screen for two or we film for two
hours I got 15 minutes of usable footage
it's it's a fit show about it the
multiplayer aspect was poorly coded just
saying the game itself was bad right and
I'm like oh that's juicy nonetheless
right I'm like I then I'm definitely not
going to show up and I I called my
company that was arranging everything
and I'm like hey I'm feeling a little
ill and I'm also feeling uncomfortable
about the deal and they're like you know
you have a back out clause where we you
agree to pay us if you back out from
this and I'm like well I don't agree to
pay you and I know I signed a piece of
paper but I'm never paying you and I'll
never work with you again if you try to
make me and they're like alright we're
sorry why don't you just show up and
give it a shitty review cuz I didn't
want to take a big dump on the
developers I don't mind taking a dump on
a CEO right like the CEO of epic
Tim Sweeney I'll go far out and ahem
Sweeney all day right but I don't want I
don't want to take a dump on the
developers who work on fortnight I don't
want to take a dump on the people who
are working on the storefront in epic
the people Tim Sweeney hires Tim
Sweeney's making decisions Tim Sweeney
bonuses right yeah by pushing out an
uncomplete game that's not on the
developer right right it's never on the
developer it's always on the guy who
gets that twenty million dollar bonus at
Activision yeah it's always on that it
Bobby Connick it's always I'm part
economy so I will I will bully Bobby
Kotick all day but I will not bully a
single person that works under Bobby
Kotik because why would I see it's he's
under the pay grade if you get a 20
million dollar bonus you're damn right
I'm gonna talk [ __ ] about you on the
other and so when you didn't show up was
there beef with Ubisoft they are
actually really cool about it because I
think they understood that the state of
the game but they all come right it's
probably it right right actually the
whole things off but then like Ed Boon
flew me out to play Mortal Kombat 11 and
I will tell you right now I
the gameplay loop for Mortal Kombat 11 I
love if you go to the story mode if you
go to the the local fighting or the
online fighting you will never notice
the microtransactions they're just not
built into the game in a way that annoys
you right but if you go to the towers of
time or if you go to the Crypt or if you
go to the customization it's right there
in your face and looks of course I have
to complain about that right and I feel
so bad because I love Ed Boon and I love
the Mortal Kombat game loop and I love
the entire franchise and I got the
flower to play the game but of course
I'm making a video talking about that
you have to write like it if I don't
have my integrity on YouTube then what
do I have that we live and die by our
integrity right so I felt super bad but
I'm like trashing Ed's game you know
it's worth buying if you like the
gameplay loop but they should never deal
with it with him Dylan microtransactions
and there's something else that really
bothered me about Mortal Kombat 11 and
this is I think this will be the viral
clip that makes Twitter mad at me so get
ready everybody buckle up but I'm
playing through Mortal Kombat 11 and I'm
playing the story mode and at one point
Shao Kahn says actually to me honestly I
don't remember him saying it personally
experiencing it I've seen other people
talk about it though I think it is in
story mode it might be in like one of
his lines so you haven't seen it you've
seen a clevy people talking about I've
seen people talk about it uh-huh but I
didn't pay that much attention to the
story mode I just wanted the rewards I
mean hear about the story I skipped it
through a lot but at some point
apparently Shao Kahn the big bad of the
Mortal Kombat series says make Outland
great again that's why I'm wearing the
shirt I'm wearing today this is my most
political shirt yeah soren running for
yeah that's a bad that's a bad take on
great again right so our make
middle-earth right good again right
maybe Mordor that's a bad but so you
have Shao Kahn emulating Donald Trump
and all I can think is some to play
Mortal Kombat 11 it's like can i play
one game without remembering one
apocalyptic statement that's there I
think it's almost a prism left guy samus
gave me Mortal Kombat 11 used to be all
escapism Mortal Kombat is escapism yeah
right you're literally ripping people's
tits off and feeding him to them right
like that's the entire point of the game
is to escape reality yeah and and now I
have to I don't want can I not think
about Donald Trump for like a day is
that a thing I could do
not because I thought no you can I'm a
huge Stephen King fan love Stephen King
I fought Stephen King on Twitter twelve
years ago when he created his tweeter
Twitter right and I created mine and he
would talk about its books and to talk
about his family and talk about it these
families books and we talked about like
the movies they were making a lot of
falling Stephen King and now all Stephen
King does his tweet about Donald Trump
ten times a day 20 times a day 30 times
a day and I don't disagree I do not
disagree with a single thing that
Stephen King has to say about all from
but can we talk about your books can you
write a book man can you make a movie
can we have 12 minutes where I'm scared
of a [ __ ] monster again that's not a
living actual monster in this country
Stephen King would probably say that he
it's probably just what's up you know
what's in his brain you know just the
way he's they and let's I mean Donald
Trump is the king of getting attention
of course right like he's he loves all
the more reason to not give him the
attention but yeah I agree with you I I
have found myself like I used to be fan
of the late night shows the Fallon's the
Jimmy's and all the Jimmy is not the Jim
not all the Jimmy's the Kimbell the
Kimball's and it's like you know
especially Colbert's unwatchable now
like I was a big fan of The Colbert
Report and he's just I look at him and I
still watch because there's nothing to
watch ever on television I wonder every
night I wonder to myself why the [ __ ] am
I paying for dish
raaah hey it's so expensive for so many
commercials and there's never anything
to watch that being said I look at
Colbert and I'm like this hack it's all
he talks about is Donald Trump's
exhaustion and I and I hate how he just
assumes that everyone who watches a show
like as on his page you know where he's
like well Donald Trump's the biggest
[ __ ] loser in the world and
everyone's like right right it's like
well I know a lot of Trump supporters
and that's weird right
not very many in Arkansas because
there's very few and where I live in
Arkansas hmm but a lot of people where I
grew up in Virginia mm-hm and most of
them do not like Donald Trump they do
not like him as a person they do not
like his politics what they voted for
they wanted the coal mines to
reopen they wanted him to try to bring
business back to like jobs to America
and that's why they voted for him and
they'll vote for him again because they
hope that's what happened he's gonna get
him right you can't explain to him
you can't yeah I joke about being super
Idol on stream all the time and people
are like why I'm like dude I don't live
through a second trump presidency it's
not like it's not even really Trump's
like I don't like the trumpet's policy I
see a stereo going on a nation I can't
handle it you know besides of whoever
whatever you think about Trump I'll go
on the record and say that he's not my
guy right he's definitely not my guy
he's not my guy opposite oh my god but
it's it is exhausting and it's like and
it is interesting how the media is so
especially all the late night it's just
like a giant circle jerk where they're
all like rubbing [ __ ] and coming on
each other people want cuz Colbert's
number one and he talks the most he's
really funny I mean don't get me wrong I
get it I still walked out I'm starting
to doubt that they have these intro
sketches every time and it's like the
dumbest thing we should get a we should
get like a compilation of his intro
sketches watch her no I don't know I
agree you know who I like John Oliver
he's okay he's a little smarmy like he
is yes he has his moments but what is
valid what I like about it is it's often
educational and he's those are my
nothing he's nothing like a centrist at
all right but when he attacks I have
friends and family who have been
addicted to opiates right and when he
attacks the the people who created that
that loop for those fear yeah I'm just
like I couldn't get more of John on yeah
is that right and it's when he does
Trump when he does the other stuff he
does in a way that I think I learn
something so I never mind cuz I love to
learn but I never feel like I learned
from Stephen Colbert because it's
absolutely er it's clowning right yeah
but even if I don't agree with John
Oliver I learned from John all do you
watch 60 minutes very rarely in Utah
yeah yeah 60 minutes is one of the best
shows watch YouTube
I might actually but they I mean they're
like about the opiate
phenomenon right right much and they
really put people on blast and they
absolutely showed right like when you
look at what they were doing with most
of the really high-end oxycontin I took
oxycontin after my surgery how is that
legal I was well I'm morphing directly
through my mouth I couldn't believe
certainly shouldn't be so what the 60
minutes what report they've talked about
like the first of all the drug companies
that knew it was super dangerous and
super addictive that had it classified
by the FDA as suitable for use for
everyday use so they fought our with the
FDA and they make it suitable for
everyday use so they're being sued and
fought over like the the nicotine the
cigarette companies were you know like
decades ago but at the same time there's
also stuff like pain clinics have you
heard about this and that's unbelievable
you've got these crooked doctors that
are setting up pain clinics and like
there was one city like somewhere in in
the rural central united states that
imported enough oxycontin pills that it
was like a thousand per resident of that
city of that city right right like and
so they're like how is it possible that
this isn't raising any red flags either
with the drug manufacturer or the FDA or
any regulatory because they're basically
importing tons of drugs through one
crooked doctor and and then becoming
drug dealers and evil its army to
definitely angles yeah right and so they
were saying that at some of these pain
clinics there's just lines out the door
like hundreds thousands of people every
day just coming here and they're handing
out oxycontin
it's crazy it blew my mind this story so
I think in LA and New York and these
kind of big cities it's it's easy to
forget what this epidemic is but there
are people dying like literally dying oh
in small towns like the small towns
rather than the small town of my ex-wife
now lives in the small town she lives in
is it's called well she's not directly
in it but there's a town near called
Escanaba and they literally called meth
kanava because of how bad the drugs
problems are there and the people that
have stayed there have either stayed
there because they're rich and the only
and they're our own business
there or it's people who just couldn't
escape right and so they're such a small
drug force there they can literally do
whatever they want that you can sell
whatever you want and no one's there to
stop you no one's there to bust you and
these people are all miserable so they
turn to drugs yeah and the profit is
through the roof I know it's legal or
illegal they don't give a [ __ ]
the doctors participate there the drug
dealers did you're not gonna bust it if
you drive over from New York to this
part of Michigan and distribute to one
of your dealers there and have him live
there you're just gonna make a fortune
and no one's ever gonna find out it's
crazy it's really insane
I love sixty minutes though that's like
the last great journalistic show a my
opinion that's not partisan they're just
like beautiful they don't how it is and
it's really powerful
actually just because of what it is I
feel like we are getting to a point
where we're starting to have real
journalists again and I will use an
example here and I Dona hate me using in
the example but there is a journalist at
Kotaku called Jason fryer and Jason has
done some really interesting expose days
he did an expose on the game anthem and
why it failed and Bioware's overworking
culture and how there was only 18 but
luckily he went in and they found people
that worked for Bioware and talked to
them about the experiences there and
created an expose very similar to what
reporters used to do in the 80s right
they he blew the lid off of a real story
and it wasn't for political gain it
wasn't for social justice reasons here's
to try to make the gaming industry
better mm-hmm
and I literally applauded him I slid
into his DMS the next and I'm like this
is actual journalism you were doing
actual journalism please keep doing it
and I don't think he even responded to
me because I don't think he likes me but
yeah but like it's a following
yeah I know I think he used to and
that's why I can still be mmm like
exchange words not nice words at some
points too but I like have so much
respect for that guy because he's doing
actual gaming journalism and actually
exists and he's doing it and like I want
to celebrate that man I want to applaud
that man I want to just write him a
check and just do this more please can
we have that in this nation not report
on your feelings but report on facts and
like get actual sources to talk about
stuff and not
besides it like you said tell the story
yeah they're out there but they're not
you know increasingly less it's people
want juice man of course I want that
juice right let me ask it did you watch
the new game of Thrones I do can we talk
about that and do you think that we're I
mean everyone who's a fan would have
washed it by now right uh yeah pretty
much right I can't see anybody being
really yeah honestly and even after
watching it I was like you couldn't
really spoil this it's like it just is
what it is right I was on YouTube
trending dude I was watching everything
the trending tab and there was a [ __ ]
spoiler on [ __ ] this was like
number three on trending it shows Arya
stabbing
yeah trending YouTube I have a fan
account mojo I have a fan account
um the Sammy 298 it's you know a fan who
pretends to be my dog on Twitter and he
spoiled Game of Thrones 30 minutes after
was over with a tweet and everybody's
like boogie you piece of crap you're
spoiling like number one I'm not
spoiling anything that's a fan number
two have you checked Twitter because
it's literally on the trending page
right now yeah so we wanted to talk
about that because Dan had some gripes
with it pretty happy with that I enjoy
every second yeah yeah I did
I actually did I understand the
criticism though because like the
criticism being first of all I agree
like when the night king was defeated
like that it's like damn he can't he
entered the game and immediately left
like you have though at that build-up of
the whole series was this showdown I
mean the the series is called you know
Ice and Fire the Song of Ice and Fire
well that ice that ice it's not really
song it's more of an ice of fire like a
little the story of of icicle it's
because they went with a short season
right like that cookies they wrapped
that battle could have taken place over
two or three episodes right and you
could have the scene where Arya is
inside the the little thing you have
these conversations and the Crypt lasts
longer it should have been two or three
episodes right yeah they just like I had
to do it in one episode because they're
doing us six episode season or whatever
reason I don't write really long episode
when you think about it was it was hour
and a half yeah but I think that um it
was
mark - I have an HDR TV I'm like like so
I guess that was okay yeah we always
turn the lights off and even then on my
70 inch HDR I'm like why there was lots
of comments about the dark yeah but I
loved that whole beginning widows down
are me that was oh that was so yeah it
did exactly like he's number one here's
my biggest complaint about that why
would those swords go out if they have a
spell cast on him just because somebody
died it doesn't make any sense the
swords would go out right okay because I
played it up there's a blizzard they had
some babies right right but I remember
the Dragons got lost in the blizzard oh
that's nice you might be right yeah but
the whole the whole thing was it was
really good storytelling right like that
moment I'll never forget that moment
it's the swords begin to fall and the
darkness takes over I'm like it's really
poetic it's really beautiful and I saw a
lot of people complaining about it I'm
like with it was a complaint uh well it
was like that's not realistic
this sword should still be on fire right
oh and I'm like dude that's your
imagination right I'm like dude stop you
were watching snow with zombies and
Dragons you are complaining about swords
going out bro it's date they have a ice
spell right just whatever we on right
whatever reason you want to make up is
fine well that wasn't yeah I didn't I
but but I understand it's like the night
king you have this epic build-up and
then all the sudden she's like boom game
over you know mostly brand and brand
that useless Kim nothing happened that
was beyond Greyjoy was the character I
most wanted to live yeah cuz I feel like
I can relate to the character because
like I feel like emotionally were kind
of similar characters that's sad but
that's true right up your penis though
right examine as much as a 400-pound guy
can you know they say for every hundred
pounds you lose yeah you gain back an
inch and I'm up to two inches now man
wait I'm hoping one day it'll be usable
as I get fatter my dick gets smaller oh
definitely yeah though I don't know what
the question is with your penis
I haven't any not an outie yeah
helmut [ __ ] myself and i'm like i
already can you see your penis now like
how is the visibility great it's really
great I can do like actual sex it's
weird yeah I can commit sex on somebody
if they let have you had indicated he
lost a lot of weight mm-hmm and so
what's the difference well at 600 pounds
there was one position that worked that
was reverse cowgirl
basically they you lay down and they
yeah they do the word right word so it's
easy to make sure you're maintaining
consent because if they get bored
there's get them leaf yeah right cuz I
wouldn't do anything other than like
letting it happen
and so now what positions are you um
there's there's a few things we can do
like reverse cowgirl still great cowgirl
still great right but sure like if
you're willing to handle my little skin
we can do other stuff you can do like
doggy hi doggy yes I think we spoke with
that and you put the fat on the girl
yeah man and I skin now it's not bad
it's a skin I will show you if you guys
want to see gross [ __ ] oh you're gross
yeah now we're good okay I just showed
it on my youtube channel
yeah of course here's the next viral
moment Twitter's gonna get mad about
this but so I've gained and lost weight
my whole life so obviously there's still
a tremendous amount of fat here right
you want to talk about Fupa do ya
mmm-hmm look at what I'm like at this
solution and this is all loose skin and
my doctor tells me he wants to do
cosmetic surgery I don't think it's
cosmetic at this point you know why you
hit him by doing do it yeah we're okay
can I tell I almost want to touch it by
the man I'm a little sweaty because the
airs not working in here right now but
yeah look at it's just loose miserable
skin that's fine I have it here - I have
it leather like the mantis-like play
with that that's fun like an old man
never felt that much that's interesting
so so when you're having sex it's more
like lift it up put it on your butt go
to town right and other girls that are
into that there are girls who have put
up with it I've Mountain met a girl who
was like oh I want you wrinkled skin all
over my face right right and so that's
the thing like a lot of people think I I
really like womanized or whatever I've
gone out with like made a lot of female
friends in the last year right but for
the most part you it's you got to be a
special person before I take you back
home and show you this mess you have
trouble like performing when you're
heavier because I had my biggest yeah
yeah right because I was having hormonal
issues like I was producing next to no
testosterone fat produces estrogen so I
had all these like hormonal confusion
confusing blockers I still was able to
get there every time I never had
completely performing but that means
you're gonna be like you're gonna be M
will be honest and it's your is your
erection quality improves since you've
lost weight since I started taking
testosterone but losing weight right how
many do you have you ever tried taking
like viagra something like that no but I
did start taking the antidepressant at
the beginning of the year yeah and it's
a very common thing where you have
trouble finishing yes and so some girls
have really liked that and some girls
have really been annoyed by that you can
tell which ones actually you're enjoying
wrap it up when they can wrap it up when
they're done right right yeah I have I
started taking that's the really the
only side effect I've experienced is
that my dick has lost like a lot of its
sensation you know which makes it hard
to finish and I feel like my dick has
shrunk to I don't know if it's writing
my dick drunk you would know yeah I
don't know you've been saying that ik
yeah I don't know if it's cuz I'm
getting fatter or older but like I used
to be proud of my dick and now it just
looks pathetic right well that's part of
getting older to you right I don't know
I've gone through the reverse thing
because I've lost some weight what's
wrong I'm like oh my god look at me my
two inches
I'm massive now yeah there's nothing
there's I mean being proud of your penis
is one of the best thing great fantastic
as a man but you could look at your dick
and be like right on bro right so I
think that I think I need to be proud of
my dick again mm-hmm you should be you
should be proud I noticed and are you
proud of it it's not about what you
think about my deck ELA it's about how I
feel when I masturbate bro yes but but
yes strange concept right
yeah oh I like having women in my life
and like having female friends right but
you you got to be a special ass girl
before I take you back to my place and
be like hey here's this fucked-up body
do you want to see it yeah but you got
to own it I mean nobody there's no
there's no I like that look if I do
enough I'm like this is my body do you
record yeah if they say no then they
leave
yeah but soon you're gonna be dude
you're gonna be a slim tight little
twink rock I work I have so I've really
been plateaued at about 340 pounds for a
while now it's been the struggle in
between 30 40 and 350 and I know what I
need to do my friend Diamond Dallas Page
wants me to come and stay with him for a
couple weeks to get in the
accountability crib and my exercise and
eat right and just like film it and and
cherrylle my audience and I really want
to do it I think I'm gonna do it after
the Khan season where I'm traveling all
this summer but the biggest thing I
really want to get the skin rule yeah
and my doctor told me when he was
looking at this stomach last time he's
like that's 30 pounds right there yeah I
would literally pound so I'm 340 but
maybe I'm a little closer to 320 or 310
right because yeah and then there's a
probably another five ten pounds up here
with the the breast tissue so there's
like one surgery here another surgery
here I don't think they'll do both at
the same time maybe they will I don't
know what I don't want to do it twice
but originally I said I would never do
it I don't want to do it every now it's
become such an issue it's such a
terrible I did you think that you
wouldn't want to do the syndrome of
yours look I don't care abut it like an
actual encumbrance right exactly right
you know I I guess on some level I am
human I do would like to be attractive
one time that's not right it's not but
you don't have to be feel ashamed to
want to look right but I mean at the end
of the day it's mostly just painful and
annoying and and it's causing health
concerns now yes eventually I will do it
what's your diet like well what's your
everyday regimen do you have bad days on
diet bad days right like it's a bad day
look like a bad day is like I'm Mexican
for dinner and I'll eat like I'll go get
fajitas and only like two burritos
because that's all I can fit in like two
tortillas where the bria and I'll put in
the fridge and then for dinner I'll have
two more and like that'll finish the
meal and some that bad I know but the
weight how's that bad that's not bad
because I mean it's still best 1500
calories right there 1,500 calories and
so if I had a normal breakfast of like
responses to bacon into eggs are looking
at 600 calories there and then so is
that what your normal breakfast looks
like bacon and eggs I've been doing a
lot of turkey bacon and egg whites now
lately to try to reduce calories a
little bit but that leaves me so hungry
that by the time I'm done with working
for the day I'm stressed because I'm
right it's so hard I'm trying to lose
weight and it's just I've talked about
this before but it's so hard for people
that don't have like a fat gene to
understand like what hunger right and
you know you're not hungry like I've
been eating for breakfast like a bowl of
unsweetened oatmeal just with water and
some berries and that's it and it's good
I enjoy it it's really wholesome but you
get so [ __ ] hungry you know towards
the middle of the day that's not your
problem though I mean I get like when
I'm hungry I immediately feel it it's
like painful because I'm there's not
much a problem right but then I go be
small yeah I mean I see with you you'll
just get this idea in your head all of a
sudden it just doesn't go away until we
get pizza that's what I like about the
surgery though like greasy foods like
pizza most of time just makes me really
ill for real right it's kind of nice so
what do you pick out on what's your like
you're a far too much fruit at home
fruit come on really
too much but like I do eventually
Reese's Cups are like one of my biggest
things right I had a mate go to Walmart
why and I'm like two weeks having that
one two weeks everyone up the bigs for
the minis probably the biggest like how
many big can you really go hard like two
would be really hard now that's come on
that's not that honey man it's you know
but I might have ilysm took a huge hit
with a surgery that's one of the biggest
issues right you mean it's slow oh you
mean right slows because my boy I went
through starvation mode for two years
right so if what my doctor says is to be
believed like I'm taking a bit of a hit
to the metabolism it'll hopefully
regulate at some point right but but
yeah I'm on a really bad day I eat 3500
calories which is enough to maintain 340
pounds and that's probably like that's a
lot right yeah and I'm like a really
good day 2500 you know like that's me
it all comes down to stress and it all
comes down to comfort eating like
there's this youtuber I won't mention
any names but he made a video about like
I said on twitch one night I'm like I
don't know that I'll ever get smaller
than 350 pounds cuz I'm really happy at
my current size and the reason I said
that was not because I'd given up I said
that because a lot of people are really
worried about me and I wanted to stop
worrying I wanted them to know that I
was happy where I currently am right I'm
not gonna gain the weight back I'm gonna
try to maintain this and I'm probably
keep losing but I want you to know that
I'm happy that was the important part of
that story but they turned it into who
he's encouraging people to stay fat and
he's gonna die in the next year and all
the stuff right and it's super
frustrating cuz that's number one that's
not what I said that's not what I meant
but okay whatever uh hey I just wanted
people to know that I was happy and I'm
so mad remembering this that I feel like
I I feel like I've lost track um have
you are you in therapy oh yeah I'm in
again your problem Oh Tara piss recently
actually really because I went in and
I'm like I'm dealing with online hate
and I'm like losing subscribers I've
been because subscribe to youtube.com
slash look at you tonight but I've been
losing subscribers for a while and it's
really frustrating because YouTube is
telling me what used to work doesn't
work anymore and I'm really mad about it
and I'm getting a lot of online hate and
I don't know how to deal with the online
hate and he's like would it help if I
subscribe to you you know well I'd be
showing you support would you like that
kind of support and I'm like you so
don't get yeah I stopped for a while and
reconnect these it's like forties
fifties right good finding it they're a
good therapist is super tough right and
that's if you're ever shopping for a
therapist you have to be aggressive and
you have to find like I'm sure you're
aggressive about your OBGYN I'm sure
you'd be aggressive about your cancer
doctor you be aggressive about your
general practitioner be even more
aggressive about your therapist because
if you don't click it's not gonna work
huge problem is to that you have niche
you haven't kind of a niche issue or
your internet right celebrity exactly
which I think in Arkansas you probably
don't have a lot of people that
understand don't I mean and it you don't
have to be anyone could potentially have
insight to understand what that is but
like you have a lot of therapists out
here in LA that have have experience
treating people with that who are
performers that's interest right out his
phone therapy exists I should find one
in LA he wants to be like bone sessions
yeah
it's possible I do you think you could
find someone who's insightful and
talented to dream you there but I just
think that people are the doctors I
worked with don't get me wrong like he
helped me so much with the divorce if
he's listening I apologize you know you
he helped me so much with my divorce
their office is a very good office
everybody there is very talented he's
very good at what he does that said in
that one area he just rubbed me really
wrong yeah how do I deal with that right
yeah that's that was the primary focus
of what I needed then I've made it
through the divorce I had made it
through the surgery I made it through
and he was very helpful with that but
now this is my primary issue what do i
do how do I fix it well I could click
subscribe on your YouTube channel that's
like some mom [ __ ] yeah you know what I
mean yeah I'll subscribe to you he's a
cool guy was a clean Oh what am i yeah
it's tough it's a tough problem I don't
know that there's a solution I think the
well I will say and I said on the show
last time I'm very fortunate to get to
talk to a huge number of graders through
all the shows and stuff I do and because
I'm og
a lot of creators grew up watching me
and now that they've made it and gone
far past me they still treat my love and
respect and it's when I go to shows I
get to talk to everybody and universally
creators are anxious universally
creators are depressed mm-hmm that comes
apart with being a creative type right
because most creative types are dealing
with anxiety depression stuff like that
yeah but when it comes to the laser
focus of the internet and the way people
treat each other on Twitter because I
still believe I said it on the show last
time I got backlash understanding on the
show last time I'll say it again I think
the way we treat each other is wrong I
think we need empathy not hatred I think
we need to give people second chances
not destroying one the first mistake I
think that we need to get people an
incentive and an ability to learn from
their mistakes and become better people
and that's
we will ever have good people you can't
do - James Gunn what you did the James
Gunn you can't do it you can't do it and
I'm glad they I'm glad they took it away
I'm glad they took a step back and I
hope we see start seeing more stuff like
that because when even when you make a
real mistake even you make a big mistake
and say something truly stupid it is
possible to allow that person to
continue to exist learn from their
mistakes be a good example and become
better people and I will always believe
that and no matter how much hatred I get
for it treating each other with vitriol
is wrong it will not solve the problem
well obviously that's not I mean that's
not a controversy it is because when you
tell bullies at that bullying doesn't
work you get bullied that's what
happened I think the problem I think
I've learned a lot I think in these past
years of having dealt with dealt with
things went through a lot I think really
it comes down to being able to
compartmentalize like reality from from
fiction right and unfortunately I think
that social media is not going anywhere
and what it does is just it amplifies
you know negativity of course it's
designed like you want to hear the black
pill version of me and what I'm about to
say I genuinely believe this is not
hyperbole I genuinely believe that
social media is designed to divide us I
generally believe that Jack and and
Zuckerberg and all these people that are
running these websites know that it's
profitable and know that it makes them
more more rich and more powerful than
angry we all read each other the more we
fight that's why not only is it natural
human interest that we are interested in
the juice that were interested in the
drama that we're interested in attacking
each other that we love being vitriolic
that we love being anonymous on the
internet attacking each other but they
know that that's not only what we do but
it's profitable to let us do it give us
an arena to do it to encourage us to do
it and you know jack God love you I
believe that when Zuckerberg and Jack
and all these guys make their changes
they only make changes right up to the
point that they can't be sued anymore
because that's what they care about sure
I believe I believe that there's a
possibility that that's true I think
that we are just not well equipped as
human beings to deal with that kind of
of floating consciousness of like social
media and what it does to us I think
we're gonna get better at it I hope
because you have to learn basically that
what you see and hear there is not
really real right right and if it feels
real it's what you see and it's what you
hear but again the people that watch and
support you I mean you have to be a
little bit psychotic to go and leave a
hate comment as a Negroni right yeah
maybe I have no I haven't left a hate
comment on anything I mean since I was I
don't know ever I don't know I don't
know people people people have said to
me like you like everything and I'm like
no there's a lot of stuff I don't like
yeah but I don't talk about the things I
don't like well you can talk about
things you don't like well I will for my
business for like like you know I went
to a game company messes up and I want
to encourage the game come to get better
I'll talk about that right but like if I
don't like a creator I can aim for
creators off top of my head I don't like
but I very rarely talk about any of them
right now I'm not a huge fan of Jake and
Logan I'm sorry guys you guys screw up a
lot right that's what else give me some
good I'm just kidding I'm not but okay
no this douchebag who made this video
encouraging my fans to distance
themselves for me because I'm Pat that
guy I'm not going to say his name but
like why do that why did that have a lot
of views that video you know like as
many views as my videos get these days
in the hundred thousand where you know
so it's like it's it's it's hard but it
really is you have to I think the the
pursuit that we all have as as people
today and especially entertainers is
like the pursuit of authenticity it's
like you have to have a frame you have
to pursue this idea of authenticity
within yourself that gives you
confidence and ground to stand on right
it's it's simple but it's like the
hardest thing to do in your life for me
it's almost like a a lifelong pursuit
because what does it mean to to be
authentically yourself how do you do it
and at the soul the center of what it
means is being having a confidence to
know and believe in the things that
you're doing we're the right things it
represent who you are right when I was
first coming up being authentic wasn't
wasn't a problem I didn't even have a
choice everything I did was authentic
but then when you start hearing voices
and dissent and thoughts and
tell you know this is how this is you
authentically or this is you
authentically or you've changed so
that's your not authentically you
anymore they like this content but they
don't like this you know it all goes
into your right consciousness if you
think about it or not and you're really
you're struggling with the housing voice
is ten thousand words a million voices
all saying different things it's like a
version of schizophrenia it right right
and eventually you just have to separate
yourself from and you seem to have done
that entirely for the most not entirely
right but for the one thing I've been
working a lot towards you have to be
your authentic self and if you listen to
that stuff you can't anymore after the
last two years
yes I would read what they were saying
on these forms and these subreddits and
some I'll read and be like oh my god I
need to change things I'm different the
lives like those people never gonna like
me no matter what I write you don't have
any way they literally they don't I owe
you is saying they don't know you
exactly
they don't [ __ ] know anything about
who you really are I saw it I saw a
tweet the other day had your name in it
and I was up there next year and it was
a list of people that PewDiePie followed
who were Nazis oh yeah I thought it was
me you yeah how plain Adar you and Nazi
here's something else somebody said I
was in our article it was it was
actually got a lot of coverage it's
insane Alpha Omega sin were a guy out of
Texas he's he's very lbgtq plus a sort
of friendly as I know right apparently I
have transphobic which I literally I own
a gaming store now I just put fifteen
grand into a new gaming store and yes
that is a profitable thing right so I'm
not an angel I'm not a saint I plan to
make my money back because it's a store
but we owned one store called ye er need
to make that caveat of course because
that's people try to take away what I'm
about to say right and I don't want to
let him I don't want to let him all
right no because after after upsetting
the lbgtq bin the last time I was here I
wanted to make up for it and I don't
talk about this very often I'm talking
about it now a year later you know but I
don't talk about this stuff very often
the way I made up for it is a transplant
of mine Olivia Tosa at oats olive on on
Twitter if you want to go for give her a
follow she opened up a store called gear
and when she opened up I bought a bunch
of cards from her personal collection to
help open the store and the reason I
wanted to do
because she was going to register it as
an OB GT coupe plus a stone and if you
hear the word say Sona you roll your
eyes let's say so a SafeZone specific
safestone right and if you hear the term
SafeZone and you roll your eyes because
who wouldn't need that we are in
Arkansas that first store was two hours
away from Harrison Arkansas where the
current Grand Wizard of the Ku Klux Klan
lives we opened our lbgtq plus safe zone
in clan territory people okay and and we
did this what the safe zone means is of
course it's a safe zone for everybody
right no matter who you are come play at
our store you're gonna have a good time
at our store you won't have to deal with
politics or hate or anything or a gaming
store but if you're an lbgtq plus member
we have someone on site who can counsel
you and help you deal with life issues
you're feeling suicidal if you're having
trans issues if you're having problems
getting bullied in Arkansas if the claim
is breathing down your back come to us
we will help that's what our that's one
of the things our store offers so the
owner of the store my friend Glenn says
to me I want to open another one an hour
and a half away will you give me some
money I cut him a check right there I
didn't think about it will you register
this one as a no TVT kills so so yes
well Illinois the Klan yes here's my
money well I'll pay you back I hope you
do because I would like to have the
money back but as it is right now I'm a
partner in the store let's kick some ass
and if I get the chance I'll open one an
hour away from Arkansas AR from Harrison
and then now half an hour from Harrison
I'll build one in Harrison and let it
burn them let them burn it down
but the internet thinks I'm anti lbgtq
on what plan that's the so that's the
thing is like most I'm sure that first
of all you know yourself you are the
people that know you know that you
aren't people your fans your actual fans
which is the vast majority of people who
consume your content I would assume
right know that you aren't so again
you're you're facing an unreality you
are responding to it's a madness really
happening it is maddening it's totally
medic and I don't think we're equipped
to deal that's what I'm saying like to
deal with that insanity but we have to
first acknowledge that it is insanity
right and that that's what I mean the
the pursuit of authenticity right
because you have the whole concept of on
tête authenticity get
so mixed up what other people expect
from you or the fact that we change over
time as online personalities that we are
we have to be allowed to evolve we can't
stay in a stasis that's not authentic is
right so you have to know who you are
you have to know what you're about and
and it is such a difficult thing but
when you know when you really know who
you are authentically and you can be
yourself fluidly then then I think
that's what can help nullify these
voices that but for me I just I I tried
to not engage with them as little as
possible I'm trying really hard not to
it's very difficult because I have an
anxiety disorder and I get very anxious
and I will dissociate and when I'm
dissociate I need to not have my phone
near me because I will talk to somebody
for 20 minutes and not even control of
what I'm saying well so it's a problem
with not just us but everyone like for
example Twitter reporting some stupid Oh
the internet was upset about this news
nobody was maybe and fuse that's what
Jack does he makes his money that's how
that's how that platform gets investors
but then it's not just then it becomes a
story on articles and you know it yeah
and I think you're right about that they
are stirring up drama for profit the one
that really reminds me of that Shane
Dawson story that was on Twitter news
that he's like a pedophile Twitter runs
this story in the headline it's a
non-story that they created from like
one random [ __ ] and it gets blown up
into this huge story
that's that is actually a bigger problem
because I mean that's like fake news you
know right you're creating a that's why
I mean that's just you know that slander
that's just libel level we need to know
how to separate this stuff but then for
reporters for example they also need to
know not to take it at the same give it
I came again one of my biggest focus is
the gaming world and like as much crap
as I gave Mortal Kombat 11 there are
people actually reporting that it takes
six thousand dollars to unlock
everything in Mortal Kombat or you can
play the game idiot like literally Edie
Boone had to come out and say no most of
the skins that that you can
by our our purchase play role through
the game and most of the skins that are
playable through the game you can't buy
like what are you talking about you
people are lunatics right but it doesn't
matter because all these gaming channels
see that one headline that was falsely
reported and then they run with it it's
absurd it's a certain you know I I've
done that a couple of times I've taken
Kotaku at their word polygon at their
word and and thought oh look at the
sources didn't verify myself reported it
and then had to take the video down
because I fought like an [ __ ] well
that's fun I mean we all fall prey to it
it's it's everywhere but I think even
not just like entertainers but everybody
I think is gonna be faced with we have
kind of an existential crisis of
identity that we all need to face with
because on Instagram you don't see
reality on on social media you're not
seeing reality and I think we all need
to find our authentic selves I think
that's like a huge a huge thing that we
all need to do it's why I love Jim
Carrey because I don't know if you've
seen this but Jim Carrey's a bit of a
space cadet these days right yeah but
he's living as a himself as he can be I
totally agree and that's why I like his
whole Twitter thing is very political I
love his cartoons though they're
freaking genius they're so funny but
he's he's being very authentic mm-hmm
yeah and so and so again people can say
whatever they want they can call him a
hack that can call him part whatever I'm
sure they say terrible things about him
but that you know he's Teflon right he's
authentic and so that's kind of what
I've been trying to deal with I do think
that disc like I almost never it's a
shame because you want to engage with
the good people that care about you and
write and well but ultimately you kind
of got to not take that too because like
what can have it's not a critic also
right in a sense but it's like you know
they don't know who you are they don't
know you I've had people say you saved
my life
and I'm like no either the work yeah I I
provided the temporary distraction right
or you know you because I was 500 pounds
and you started losing weight I started
losing weight I've lost even more than
you you helped me with that
no I didn't I made a video you know I'm
glad that it registered in the world in
some way but you're giving me
far too much credit because you had to
do the dieting you had to do the work
you're stronger than me you're better me
you were more successful than me
well what planet am I responsible for
your success right but they want to give
you that I'll take it well so see you
see what you're saying it's not
I have trouble accepting compliments
like that till I actually I talked about
it with my therapist and he made an
interesting observation it's like you
have no problem
not accepting the good but you absorb
all the bad mm-hmm and you got to not
take either of it mm-hmm right cuz it's
all kind of nuts I'm gonna say
superficial not that their feelings are
but that they don't know you they don't
know you and it's great that you're what
you're creating control reaction when
we're the other right that means that
you're successfully igniting people's
emotions through through your heart form
or your my own right right but again
they don't know who you are right and
and you can't from a 10 minute YouTube
video or 10,000 YouTube videos you can't
from a 4-hour Twitter stream you can't
yeah you can't and I'm trying to be the
most authentic self that I can be right
but how do I not in a world of life
scream fails and and Twitter clips and
all this other stuff how can you be
truly authentic about life right yeah I
what I would say to you and what do I do
for myself is just to avoid it the best
thing for me because think about like
this let's say that there's a clip of me
on livestream fails from one of our
livestream that's 10,000 points and
everybody's clowning on me because I did
something super embarrassing right if I
don't see that post I am unaffected
you're right I am the same the next day
the next week that [ __ ] didn't affect me
at all I have people so dedicated to
ruining my day that they every time I
tweet they immediately like posts this
the the mall the miserable stuff that's
being said about me I have two different
people from several email accounts
because I blocking them so they change
email accounts all the time they send me
email digests of the hate I've gotten
them read it
hey you should see this look at this
terrible [ __ ] there's a we found this
out about you we found this out about
you I'll click on it it's all lies and
slanders all May
anyways something I said taking
completely out of context right yeah
you're not like you're a Hitler you're
sex out of [ __ ] whatever right and and
but it's the same people spoiled in-game
for me I think because I got an email
from so-and-so kills so-and-so at
gmail.com Oh Mike notifications on my
phone you got an email from Batman kills
the Joker right you know I don't like
wow I know I'd already got it ruined on
Twitter but at least you tried
you're right but like I there's people
out there so dedicated to me and that I
stopped playing the victim like then
these people need to stop victimizing me
well you got to stop giving them
attention like you're talking about them
now it just emboldened it's pretty
incredible that there's people out there
that care about you that much what's
hilarious it really is what I read it
for you you need to I mean you you
pulled in them and you empower them
right and I really need not to when like
somebody like somebody pointed out I
just need to delete twitter twitter
needs to be a no because that again is
giving them too much and that's why
arena so long I said in a video you
install Twitter on my phone and then 20
minutes later I got an email round up
somebody saying haha we win ha ha ha ha
and I'm like I'm reinstalling Twitter
all right now that will travel anyway
here's what you should try for a month
don't read use Twitter don't read the
mentions straight I'll look at like
verified notifications only because
those are relatively safe from those
though so then don't look at it I I
could also live without it
just use Twitter don't read the mentions
use Instagram don't read the mentions
don't go don't go to subreddits where
people are talking about you we are not
built to it you look a comment
alright I'm learning clearer right since
I got my teeth fixed I've been way
better at it it's just really hard with
an anxiety sword it's really rude for
anybody it's really you are not it's
like eavesdropping on people talking
about you when they don't know that
you're there but no they at me though
they email to me they want to know my
username on on on on reddit all the time
bro if I want anyway especially for
someone who is uh you know I used to cut
I used to self-harm I learned some
techniques like
wearing a rubber band maybe I think on
at least one of the podcasts I was
wearing a rubber band for stress relief
to harm myself
squeezing ice it was another technique I
learned to host squeeze another way to
harm yourself without leaving scars that
got me out of cutting but obviously
another form of self-harm is eating
herself to that mm-hmm and that's what
I'm I've been in one of my biggest ones
so reading this stuff is another form of
self-harm I know it's gonna ruin my day
I know it's gonna ruin my mind I know
it's gonna hurt tremendously so let's do
it because that's what I want to do I
want to be miserable because I hate
myself right I know so hard I know what
you mean to it but I feel like I like
dieting is just as important for for you
right now as to give yourself the
exercise of let's say for a day because
it seems like you you you have trouble
resisting for too long
I'd say for a day or three days or a
week or whatever you can't don't read
anything yep you know used YouTube we
used Twitter do everything don't go in
the comments just close it me for
example it was so hard if we post a
video to just post it and then not look
at I couldn't do it I could like I would
say I was gonna do it and I would still
look at but now I I really do it now oh
no no I'm gonna be like obsessively
scrubbing Twitter they you know find the
one guy that hated me and I because I'm
a piece of [ __ ] I will ignore all the
people that said oh my god you're so
grand the podcast they love you so much
you look so different you're wonderful I
love the new tail for you to not read
the comments can you try it I'm gonna
try alright so we try from this podcast
specifically if I did a podcast I
wouldn't read the [ __ ] comments I'll
say right damn now even if I thought it
went great actually
especially when I thought it went great
because I'll go there and then I'll be
like oh it was awful and now I feel
awful about it right cording to the
comments you mean right you're right my
mind and my attentive self and and in my
present mine I I thought it what I worry
about is I'm gonna be like and I was
there what what how do I hurt somebody
on this podcast who did I harm what
community or harm well how do I fix it
that's my problem my problem is I'm
someone out there's going to claim
something I said in this podcast is
genuinely hurt their community and I'm
going to make up for that their problem
right the thing that if you're really
something that would hurt someone you
would know it
exactly I'm here right now I don't think
I said anything bad and when this is
over I'm gonna be like oh we're done and
I'm not gonna look at your smart and
you're smarter than me I mean it took me
so long to actually do that I know what
you mean it's so hard but sometimes I'll
say something stupid and I'll really
regret it in my own authentic self I
will say that it was really outrageous
you did say the n-word several times
earlier in the show and I thought that
was a little surprised by that but if
you thought that was fine then yeah
here's what I will say here's what I
want here's it here's what I want to
trend let's let's see this friends let's
see if they can clip this out okay
unison on board as loud as you can I'm
gonna get way worse than that okay let's
do it
I'm gonna say to love thy neighbor Oh
get and I don't listen to me I want you
to love yo that soundboard doesn't do
that I want to say that the way the left
and the right treat each other the way
to the left and right treat each other
is not going to work and it's just going
to further divide yeah and we don't
choose empathy and we don't choose love
and we don't learn to chav
love our white neighbor and our black
neighbor our straight neighbor and our
gay neighbor our conservative neighbor
and our Democrat neighbor and our
centrist neighbors god forbid we
actually give those guys credit because
they make up the majority of the country
right god forbid that we start treating
immigrants and and and and natives and
and and citizens all the same and we
remember that we are all Americans and
some of us are trying desperately to
become Americans and we start treating
each other with love and respect and
kindness we might just end this
apocalyptic cycle we're currently in the
middle of and maybe things a bit better
because what we're doing right now sure
ain't working
yeah I you know I I Teeter on that
myself because I go I listen to the news
and I listen to the late nights and I
consume all the media and I go man it
feels so messed up right now and I go it
wasn't this bad when I was a kid and I
go well I didn't really care about
anything when I was a kid but I think
about Bill Clinton impeachments think
about how much people hated Obama if you
go back if you go back back back back
and look at like all the way back to
like Thomas Jefferson verse you know
Alex
under Hamilton or whatever that [ __ ] was
just as crazy then of course it is now
of course so I think maybe I started to
think maybe he's not that bad maybe
things are fine you know like we just
got old I think social media amplifies
everything it makes it feel way worse
than it is but overall the country is
safer than it's ever been
I mean we have trouble we have drug
problems and we have there's issues
obviously as there always will be but I
mean people are doing good overall
poverty and around the whole world is
down here's what is new here's what is
new six weeks ago fact check this if you
want because the articles are there
mm-hmm we had counter-protesters white
supremacist counter protesters on the
Capitol Steps in Little Rock Arkansas
mm-hmm chanting seven million more that
that happened yeah happened that's
reality and I know the claims always
existed I know why swainton said then
we'll anymore are they talking about the
Holocaust oh they're giving us more
credit than we because we usually we say
six and they say it's greatly
exaggerated right well then now they
have been moving more that's right you
know they believe in the Holocaust at
least I guess yeah and III where's
coming from why is this half a day at
all fixed well they don't race em it's
there I mean even during World War Two
there was [ __ ] Nazi sympathizers here
in America that's true
I'm just you know not anti-semitism is
as as classic as it gets
this is why I say this is why I struggle
with my nihilistic thoughts and like the
PTSD you like suicidal thoughts are a
very common thing with PTSD right and
and so I struggled that all the time and
I this the last two years of my life
have been simultaneously the best two
years my life in the worst two years of
my life there have been periods of time
where I was sitting in my closet with a
shotgun ready to Kurt Cobain myself
corner shot you know not that bad but I
like this is the adoration but no no
firearm no I went to purchase one but I
knew it would not be safe to have it in
my home my roommate does have one and
it's in a safe that I don't have the
code for and I don't want to have the
code for it because I know when I
dissociate I could make a very
irreparable mistake and I do not want to
do that so I do not feel safe or the gun
but that's it I've
struggle with suicidal ology in the last
couple of years don't worry I'm not
going anywhere as long as my dog's alive
I'm alive it's as simple as that or I'm
not leaving that dog leaving him for
five days like right now I'm getting
pictures from my roommate of him just
laying on my bed waiting for me to come
home I'm not leaving that dog okay but
that said I've also had moments where
I'm on a tower in Brooklyn eating lunch
with my favorite creators and and then
going to place in my favorite video game
six months before anybody else gets to
play them and and meet some of my
rockstar developers and so it's been I
don't know it's been a really
interesting couple of years but when you
when you look at III don't think I
belong in the human race and not that
I'm better I think I'm far worse because
I feel like I empathize far too much I
empathize with the wrong people I
empathize with my haters more than I do
my people who love me I swear I do I
tried more Vince them my therapist told
me you can't reason with unreasonable
people but I want to so desperately I
want to save them from their hate but
you know what my therapist told me about
stuff like that he says you have to
understand that these people are there
to hurt you you're not wrong they are
there you have to understand these are
people that are expressly expressly
going out of their way to hurt you and I
can't comprehend that I I here's a true
story people tell me I make this up I
make this up and I don't care because I
know it's true 20-some year old me and
when I got my second apartment ever I'm
sitting in this runni beatdown part of
Fayetteville Arkansas and I'm playing
video games and like 1 o'clock in the
morning Friday night and the front door
opens and a hand reaches in and starts
fumbling for the LightSwitch
and I'm like what the higher I get up
and I grab the only weapon we have in
the house which is a baseball bat and
right as he finds a light switch I swing
the door open and I'm like can I help
you and he's like oh man I'm sorry I'm
drunk and I'm like yeah clearly because
can I I'm just trying to use the phone
I'm like no you're trying to break into
my apartment why you should I cut off
light he's because those windows they're
open man I want them by seeing me in the
office I'm like this isn't an office
this is my apartment dude you're clearly
trying to rob me no no I just want to
make a phone call
who you trying to call my wife I'm drunk
I can't drive I don't want to drive home
it's 1990 a tiger grabbed my corded
phone I bring it to him I set him down
on my couch to tell him not to move I
handle my phone he calls his wife and
she screamed at him I can't believe you
drunk were you out screwing that [ __ ]
that I'm not coming to get you you walk
on he hangs up the phone defeated and
starts to walk out of my apartment and
I'm like dude are you really drunk you
guys I think I'm safe enough to drive
home and I don't think you are where you
live well I live in springdale well
that's only 15 minutes man I'll Drive
you
so a guy who might it might have been
trying to break into my home I ended up
giving him a ride home because that's
the kind of person I am
I if I died in that process he shot me
and carjacked me
I'm glad to die that way because I was
trying to help somebody right and I
think that probably makes me an idiot
I've probably not as reserved as the
rest of the human race the human race
loves vitriol the human race is
aggressive the human race is an [ __ ]
I'm a [ __ ] like whatever that word means
for you I'm probably that I am I'm a
beta male I'm a empath and and I'm too
empathic and I do it far too much the
worst thing I learned through therapy
about myself my best friend has listened
to me complain for 25 years he's seen me
dissociated he's seen me angry he's seen
me hurt he's seen me sad and I told my
therapist one day that's why I love my
best friend because he's seen me at my
worst and guess what Steve how often
does he see yours I said all the time he
sees all the anxiety from the work he
sees all the anxiety from life and the
struggles and he's helped me take a
shower and I broke my shoulder for god
sakes he's been amazing and it goes but
how do you treat strangers and I'm like
well I try to earn a stranger's trust I
give him a good experience I give him a
good time I'm kindness Rangers right I'm
very kind to strangers it's like you
gotta flip the script the person you
should be giving the good experience to
is your best friend is the people in
your life the people who support you the
people you should not give a crap about
the people you complain to the compete
pool you're mean to are the people you
don't know sure you know yeah but that's
that's always been my biggest issue I
think that's normal though I think part
of the slip up is that when we start to
think that in all
all things are normal and then that can
really drive you crazy I mean I found
that in my life and I think it's normal
that the people closest to us are the
ones we can be the shittiest too because
you become I think either complacent or
you become comfortable around them and
they can often become a punching bag and
it's not that it wasn't verbally abusive
good she's like sad and depressed and
hurt when I should be on for that person
right when I go to VidCon and I meet a
fan I am on and I'm happy and doesn't
matter how much pain I'm in or how sad I
am a that's not it yeah but I mean at
the same time you can't be on at home
right but I want to I want to for the
people who love me I want to look I want
to treat him the way they deserve to be
loved does that make sense
yeah no I know exactly what you mean
totally I mean that's part of why I went
on antidepressants because I was so
irritable and I was such a little [ __ ]
all the time such a whiny [ __ ]
many to myself because I was like just
such a punk all the time and so
irritable I'm like I knew that I was
just for the most part making ela
miserable for being around me and I
wasn't always like that you know
of course yeah and so it's actually been
a complete 180 for me in terms of
dealing with that and now you have a
baby coming along and so your
responsibility and maintain that child's
childhood is so important and it's
coming from someone who was abused
growing up and watch their parents fight
growing up and like you know I was not
sheltered from that at all I was thrown
right in the middle of it right you know
my mother claiming my father was a
homosexual because he had blood in his
underwear and like all kinds of crazy
[ __ ] and eight euro I don't know what
any of these words mean I'm eight but I
know they hate each other and I know
that apparently that's bad and cheating
on each other and I know she has a
boyfriend and like holy you know
maintain you you've got to be the best
Ethan you've ever been you know and I
look forward to seeing how that works
out yeah we're running out of time man
we got about a month left here but I
can't - it's very they're doing
somersaults how uncomfortable are you
right now like as it has been I guess
it's pretty uncomfortable like when I
need to get out of the
it's like a whole I'm making noises like
an old person now you know it's like to
be a fat guy that she's paid to do like
exactly I'm and I gotta tell you being
skinny is so much more comfortable oh
yeah cuz you're a tiny person like
that's all are you [ __ ] that oh you're
five for some reason I think you're
short but yeah you're so skinny I can't
imagine carrying that extra weight what
it's got to be like four it's got to be
a whole other experience mm-hmm and I
can't even say it like I'm you like I'm
used to I don't know it like that oh
yeah well people I can't even be myself
people complain about manspreading still
right and like when you're a morbidly
obese with all this Fred I literally
can't close my legs yeah yeah somebody
got annoyed at the the borderlands 3
event and we were like on bus together
and I was like sitting halfway in the
aisle right but I my leg accidentally
touched his leg and he's like and I'm
like dude come on
I mean I'm not sweaty I just took a
shower I don't smell bad I'm not your
typical fat guy right now I did
everything I couldn't possibly do
but I do still take up space like I'm a
human being and he wasn't a small guy
either he was like six four and so he
was taking about more than his share how
did you know he was irritated because I
just got bumped his leg and so he gave
you that got hurt right you grant them
back no I apologize yeah you should have
[ __ ] I'm a cook no I don't I don't
like that word I like the word and I
like that word and I don't like beta
mail I don't like I don't believe in any
of it that's what people call me but I
don't believe that about myself right I
I genuinely believe is that everybody's
a little bit different and in the way
that we're all different we are the same
and this is just no I choose to live my
life and I'm a product of the things and
experiences I've had and I just choose
to do whatever my brain tells me to do
and your brain might tell you to punch
that guy in the face for grunting and my
brain says hey let's make his day nice
and comfortable let's apologize and
let's you know make yourself to
defecating joke because it's just the
way I feel better about it
mm-hmm and people do whatever they do I
want you to do me a favor yeah try not
to read the comments
I'm not going to I didn't feel happy
about this we have experienced a off
Twitter to see what what one thing I
said got taken completely out of context
and used to bully me no I'm going to
completely avoid ready to figure out
what one thing I said out of context
that was used to bully me and I'm going
to try to not watch the YouTube videos
about what thing I said out of context
that will be used to bully me because
don't get me wrong I'm all for calling
somebody on their crap when they make a
big mistake right and maybe I've made
mistakes right obviously right and you
should call people out on the mistakes
you don't have to be an [ __ ] about it
that's what I think but they will and
they they're they will it's inevitable
right
it's absolutely inevitable I don't know
just try it yet try it try not to read
I'm going to yeah I'm going to how do
you feel that it's gone it's gotten
better through therapy in the last six
or seven months I've really learned how
to avoid it I just do not read read it
anymore created I created a finally
second reddit account just to read like
my magic exactly right yeah so I don't
even have to see people tagging the main
we can even block subreddits from
showing up on your feet whoo that's
interesting yeah I haven't read it and I
finally hired some mods and said you
guys just deal with it I don't care
anymore if you want to leave hate up
there leave hate up there if you want
only positivity positivity they do it
the way they want to do it I don't I
don't participate or care Twitter I have
some filters in place now tor I just
don't have to see certain key words and
stuff II I hired a guy to write a bot
that blocked everybody that used like
one particular phrase which I don't want
to say right now because I want to
emboldened anybody that was just so
tired of hearing that phrases like I'm
done with this I don't ever want to see
it mentions again mm-hmm I ended up like
blocking I think I think if bought ended
up blocking several hundred people oh
you you people who use that word who
tweeted at you you didn't lock them yeah
and I was like I just I don't want to
hear anymore I want to hear I don't see
it somebody Creator telling me they knew
somebody who could do that for me I
don't know if they logged into my
account personally did it I don't know
if they set up a bond I think they set
up a bot they did how are they did it
and I'm like II you if you use that
phrase you are an irresponsible Twitter
user and I don't care what you have to
say and you don't deserve access to my
tweets you do not deserve to see what I
have to say are they
and that's how I feel well it sounds it
sounds like it's great to see a you've
come a long way I mean look at you you
you have transformed the confidence is
coming with the change with all all
great and worthy changes come with pain
exactly they all come with pain I
already yeah absolutely look a lot worse
on camera because like my cameras
especially I haven't set the very
whitening and look it's just shocking
right you know it's it's just shocking
its system with weight loss is just
shocking it's just such a different I
got a full makeover as well my friend
Jared he's like look your bone structure
is gonna be a little different after you
the teeth mm-hm
so do you trust me to like shave you and
give you a haircut the whole nine yards
in link list let's go so he took me to a
salon and told her what to do and came
out looking very different on top of
that and they're like I chose these
frames even though I've never really
liked the thick plastic frames I had
some bruising from the surgery under my
eyes and so I was like I'll just cover
them up with the frames and people like
oh you look great
I mean alright if that's what you like I
like it too so we'll do it yes man I
just haven't still be alive at this
point because I like to told you the
last time I was here when we walked into
that surgeons for the consultation he's
like we need to rush you into surgery
you are dying now you will be dead in a
year so we're in process normally takes
almost a year I want to rush you through
and get you done within four to five
months because if I don't you will die
yeah so I'm just glad to be alive well
you look so much better
even from the last time we saw you said
you've lost 40 pounds it's it's like you
look incredible
thank you ma'am you look incredible keep
going man looking forward to the next
time we can get you out here now you
have to do another update absolutely
let's do me early yeah I'll come back in
here next year and I'll get in my old
clothes and help Oh turns out a gurney
boots are now gonna we're gonna keep you
honest I'm doing my damnedest ma'am
yeah promise you I will promise you that
I am going to either lose the rest of
weight or die trying there you go I
don't know why you need to die trying
oh because I mean we all die it's
inevitable right yeah I just want to
make sure I die doing my absolute best
right from my death
yeah yeah I hear ya well fantastic
what do anything we didn't cover that we
want to cover
we got your sex life we got the touching
the Fupa we got what we don't enjoy a
more Game of Thrones or endgame I loved
him I in-game was such a ride for me
because the very first Iron Man movie
and no spoilers obviously but the very
first Iron Man movie when they invented
the Marvel formula for that movie I
couldn't have been happier I walked to
them I hated Iron Man I thought is a
dumb character mhm and they did what
they did with it and they like cast
Robert Downey jr. and he was the best
guy ever and I'm like holy [ __ ] and then
this 11 year ride has been the best
experience of my life because I got to
see Return of the Jedi in the theater
but I need to see the original Star Wars
or Empire in the theater because I was
too young but I got to experience this
one and I hope the the younger people
out there who got to experience this
understand new experience your Star Wars
this was your Star Wars and which Star
Wars could be your Star Wars but it
can't because it's Matt Terrell now but
uh it's really bad I have no interest in
seeing the return of the Empire Emperor
or whatever the [ __ ] next one alright
right garden of scarred the rice of
Skywalker yeah watch I don't really
understand that how what does that I
don't see it's not that I don't
understand it's not I just don't care
now the last one was it will regardless
I get that I get what you're saying
about the Marvel Universe
I like Game of Thrones more personally
but I I liked endgame I thought it was
great I like the fur I thought the first
one was better
oh yeah I well it has to be better right
because you think about that and
infinity war and top right infinity war
is the Empire Strikes Back right because
the Empire Strikes Back got to
completely do something the other two
original trilogy could in the trailer to
do they literally got to do whatever the
[ __ ] they wanted they get into however
they wanted to because they have a
follow-up movie you knew that within
where they're making Empire we're gonna
get them to make Return of the Jedi so
this is depressing and crazy and weird
and nuts we can do it right and so
infinity war has the option of
completely disregarding the hero's
journey completely disregarding modern
modern storytelling and just do whatever
wanted to so by just the merits of
filmmaking it will always be the better
phone and he has to be yeah right I
enjoyed both equally but one it's
clearly the better film mmm mmm easy but
but yeah whatever I got YouTube by the
way
oh yeah what were your gripes with
YouTube you want to talk about that yeah
I'm so mad you know what's going on so
number one a lot of people wanted to
know can I still do the Frances voice
with my TV right and number one you've
heard that I have a more natural Lisp
right now but I do plan to get rid of
that Zbornak obscure the sideway Lisp
it's still pretty good in fact I think I
sound more like the original voice that
I never did expecially when I go low
because the one I'm pissed off about his
head bone that [ __ ] Mortal
Kombat my spend oh you know you got good
but this is just dead on YouTube they D
monetized my entire back catalogue and
it was a huge financial hit because
they're swearing because there's
prepared violence they start if you
curse within the first 30 seconds they
do you monetize like that I was like
what
yes I say [ __ ] at 28 minutes or 28
seconds yeah and they demonetized yeah I
video okay when they stick with it right
you literally I can't swear on YouTube
that's how pure Dan it's become yeah I'm
like dude I was talking to my guy I'm
like man I feel like this has become
worse than working with like a
television executive at this point so oh
he said to me go work with the TV
executive and then let me know how it is
but it will be like that one day I
genuinely believe it will be well it's
already again yeah
and so my friend mcjuggernuggets who did
the psycho series started an app called
story fire and I wanted to plug it here
story feiyr.com
sto ry pi re there's also an app on
Android and he's like starting creating
what he's always done is narrative
content and he wants me and kid behind a
camera and other people have just been
thrown off of youtube to come create
narrative content again because my
YouTube rep is like look could you do
Francis without the swearing can you do
Francis without getting angry
have you watched a Francis video that's
the entire character right and I've
experimented with the formula one of the
biggest experiments have been doing is
blending boogie as a character with
Francis as a character and making him
the same
and I did that for a couple of videos
did it like a stupid little podcast and
then like harass people in an airport
has the hybrid character and there was a
hybrid character I was working with
mcjuggernuggets and it's funny because
it pulls the algorithm it doesn't
realize that I'm swearing it doesn't
realize that I'm angry because they
think I'm being boogie for the first
third of the video right and then I go
into the ADC towards the end and the bot
isn't checking the last part of the
video or some reason I think it's just
the first 30 second break Lane no
literally that's what my youtube rep
said the first third always keep the
first third a clean alright the rule
I've heard specifically is 30 SEC a good
well definitely the 30 seconds but I
mean I agree I mean if he tells you a
third right then I would just time it
out and then be like but here's the
thing even with a million more there's
something that the sponsors are seeing
where they get to choose the quality of
the video as determined by YouTube now I
guess I don't know I've never been told
that but my cp/m or like the money I
earn from YouTube if I talk if I make a
gaming video I'm just going to throw
some numbers out of these numbers in
that group if I made a YouTube video and
Francis got a hundred thousand views
I might make a hundred dollars yeah I am
alone sometimes 60 sometimes forty
brought that video right yeah which is
difficult when you're breaking a 400
hour television when you're destroying
it there are excellent I made a video
and this is an actual number I made a
video about Sakura versus Kirby are not
not Kirby Yoshi and how one game is is
being dissed for being too easy in one
game is being dissed by for being too
hard right and it only got sixty six
thousand views and I made 300 bucks off
that's sixty six thousand views right
right now you tell me which is the
better choice as a creator yeah at that
point right but I want to pay my bills I
can't do Francis videos anymore that's
why I'm gonna start doing almost story
fire where I can go back to burning down
houses and wrecking cars and destroying
Xboxes Detroit televisions because it
gives me the option to keep my creative
integrity you can't keep your crazy
you're talking about being your
authentic self anymore you literally
can't be that on YouTube anymore it
doesn't matter who you are there's a
literally matter who you are you have to
edit yourself and censor yourself and
make yourself look at your abs
a little best not just because of how
[ __ ] we're all at the internet is not
just because if you make one small
mistake you're over right
but because YouTube themselves will no
longer pay you for being your authentic
self they want you to be Will Smith or
nothing else I totally agree I think
they're really have a problem on their
hands and I've been talking a lot with
them trying to get them I the CEO came
and visited us a couple weeks ago and I
spend most of time telling her why are
you guys unable to monetize this kind of
continent you have this Google preferred
program and you have all these
family-friendly channels in it making
tons of money why is it that my content
and people who make content like mine
for teens for you know mature amateur or
mature audience that you'll find on
cable television that you'll find out
radio with advertisers lined up out the
doors to target that valuable market of
more mature audience why the why the
hell can't you guys figure out how to
monetize this content because I said
what what's the what age she goes well
she goes well we've had trouble pitching
they're trying to put together like a
Google preferred for edgier channels hmm
well we were having trouble pitching it
I'm like you're not pitching it right
because when we were with complex they
used to sell direct ads on ours and it
was sold out non-stop of course it was
it was ridiculous they had junk food
they had like a you know Doritos soda
beer alcohol movies it was like every
freakin view was monetized and I'm like
dude there's no they gotta figure it out
because it's it's and why you don't just
pitch it like the Mortal Kombat you know
order MTV right here's the add your
YouTube well they need to run so it's no
they need one code they need to pitch it
like because they're all afraid that's
gonna be like Kitty's shed and terrorism
but it's curated group and you need to
picture like these are more engaged
interested audience and a specific
demographic that are willing to spend
money and different products right is
there 1835 males and most the case and
they're interested in these products and
you're going to get a better targeted
advertising advertising
to these people how would they not
figure that out so I'm pushing them hard
good she did say that they just had such
a rough last two years with all the
drama that was going on oh yeah they
were kind of like in survival mode just
trying to get out of the mess right but
the problem now and the problem is they
were in survival mode when it came to
advertisers and now they're in survival
mode when it comes to yours users
because I started using tick-tock and
make fun of tick-tock all you want but
their user base is not a joke dude and
it's because if you're a conservative
you can say whatever the hell you want
to in tick-tock IIIC conservative videos
a lot of fun I see very left-leaning
videos all the time I see shocking
content all the time there is rolls on
on there but it's not as YouTube and so
no it's not exactly monetize to monetize
the platform they don't monetize for
very many craters I think there are some
monetize creators but it's not like
anybody come on oh that's the problem
the problem is not YouTube it's the
brands they don't want their ads on that
and I think it's a problem with a
messaging by YouTube their failure to
pitch correctly I'm not saying the
tic-tock will be profitable what I'm
saying is that while the talk is going
to damage the user base it's much easier
to you know the problem is is the
brand's you're allowed to be on you and
here's where I sell out one of my
friends and I don't care when they hear
this they're gonna get mad but I know a
lot of people who work at Walmart and I
know people are working out or attacking
Walmart II and somebody from Walmart I
won't say which person specifically said
to me we don't really care about any of
that censorship crap
we really care about any AMA we care
about lowering our beds so we're gonna
do a six-month your one year hiatus and
we come back we're gonna have much lower
beds oh well that was certainly the case
when that pocalypse still happened that
they were trying or associate but I
think all of them are back now they are
but they matter they came back at a much
lower price and much lower than they've
ever been
yes I think that they definitely use
that to their advantage at the time but
I think I think like you mentioned EULA
Suzan kind of had a good point that they
were dealing with a lot internally and I
hope now that they that they can
appreciate that they need to support
people
like us because by the way our main
channel is Russia productions we get the
[ __ ] the most [ __ ] rate like the podcast
and the highlights Channel makes out
makes that are like how is that possible
we make premium content there that we
work really hard on that we package
really nicely and somehow it makes less
money than our highlights show per CPM
right right what the [ __ ] is that
because at some point the algorithm
decided that was a problem at channel
that it's rated pg-13 or it's rated PG
17 or something like that and because of
that when one of those advertisers goes
to their lodgings they choose I don't
want to be on anything controversy
alright and so they their advertisers
Larry will not appear on your channel
meanwhile meanwhile they'll still show
up on a vac rap battle all the time you
know you literally have Hitler rat
battling Darth Vader right oh that's
that's fine
right they don't curse yeah or like you
know the classic example is like the
Paul brothers who were making
pornography essentially for little kids
mm-hmm right and you've got like a girl
in the thong and the thumbnail ma'am
it's so they need to get their [ __ ]
together yeah I hope they will I mean
here's the thing I criticize I criticize
the things I love I love gaming they
criticize it right and I feel like it
can have an impact there and I criticize
YouTube because I love it
it saved my life Susan Wojcicki and and
and and and Robert Kinsel and the
decisions they have made kept me from
living a life on disability of poverty I
would've able to get the surgery I
would've been able to get these teeth if
they had not given me the opportunities
that they have given me and God loved
them and God bless them and I love
everyone I've ever met at YouTube and I
have nothing but love and respect for
him that said boy do they need to learn
how to steer the ship better yeah I
think there's a lot going on back there
that we don't can't fully appreciate by
the way meeting with her she is she's a
really a thoughtful intelligent
well-meaning lady I mean I mean I my
impression of her was very good and I
think we all need to appreciate too that
she was the one in Google that was the
biggest advocate for acquiring YouTube
that's why she's the CEO mmm so
yeah I think I think they'll get there I
think they're trying there gosh darnest
yeah I never shook her hand I I spoke to
her very briefly and at the creator
summit last year and I saw her speak of
the crater summit and you could tell how
much she loves this platform how much
she loves the craters how much she loves
what she's doing and how desperate she
is to get it right mm-hmm and you know I
heard the fact that she has toured to
see creators like you and Shane Dawson
and and everyone else and it's just been
incredible to see I wish they cared
about the small creators as much as they
care about the big craters but that's
not possible she can't meet with every
small crater she would literally be
doing it for a million years but I know
it's at this point where I don't know if
it's solvable Hank green
I love hang green he made a video
talking about platforms that might try
to compete with YouTube and obviously
the story fire thing we're doing I don't
think it's meant to compete with YouTube
but it's supplemental pretty a story for
our thing I'll tell you about what we're
doing like so he's not gonna compete but
it's there to supplement right like
roosterteeth calm whatever but if
somebody did try to compete with YouTube
you literally can't because you'll have
the same problems as YouTube right and
just like you meant even worse this and
and not pornography and all the
miserable [ __ ] they've been working for
decades on like the legal issues that
every individual country has copyright
law yeah they were they were bankrolled
by one of the biggest most successful
companies in the world because they are
only now recently actually making money
after decades right they're there the
amount of ground they've covered is like
insurmountable mm-hmm and I have to say
like it could be worse because it could
be Grande's book yeah it could be
Facebook thank you yeah you know it
could be worse it definitely could be
worse than maybe not exist
it could be Twitter yeah god forbid
right and I like Twitter just don't read
the comments I like Twitter um just like
I like sharing my life unto her you know
I've started to get way more in the
Instagram because to be honest with you
I never really Graham comments right
exactly because they're so hard to even
get they're not even look right yes and
it's just pictures of beautiful women
and beautiful people and friends I know
doing cool stuff and it's
Oh Billy the fridge is looking great a
lot of weight oh let's cats that's a
great cosplay I love this oh that's my
friend the great ghoul she's really
killing it these days and then I have a
happy experience people say Instagram is
the most depressing experience you know
place well it depends it's the happiest
cuz I'm just like all these people are
doing great well I think if you're a
young girl or even a young guy who I
mean it gets depressing because
everything you see is like people at
their best and you're just sitting at
home like also Photoshop beautiful women
who are like oh yeah when I hung out
with this way when I hung out with this
one model who posted a lot on Instagram
I won't say her name or do I call
anybody at her but hung out with her for
a while and she showed me because I met
her in real life and she's very
beautiful in real life very beautiful
real live all these women alright yeah
like Liz cats or Jessica Nigri I've met
these women in real life they're just
beautiful beautiful people right but um
this girl showed me how she further
photo shops and further filters and
showed me all these filters you can just
get on the Android store in the iPhone
store and how vastly there's been photo
that she started with and what she
posted it goes and it wasn't like she
was changing the shape of her body cuz
she didn't need to or the shape of her
face but she might put on lipstick or
she might put on Russia might put on
foundation with these makeup apps or and
then she would add filters to like
change the coloring and change the the
focus on and make the background glory
blurry so she pops out and like whole
you can do that now on them bone what
planet do we yeah it just everyone has
like perfect skin you know that's why
didn't you look in the mirror like my
skin is fair [ __ ] why am I the only
person with blackhead that's why I like
me and ugly in public yeah there's no
like come look at my YouTube channel and
you'll see gap-toothed morbidly obese
big titty man and my little lake you
feel good about yourself right thank you
we appreciate your service all right
well we're at the two-hour mark oh wow
really we black why that one there's
what could talk of all day but we got we
really come in I love you guys yeah
thank you I love having you here
Arden three four weeks away a month
can't believe it that's why that's why I
wanted to do it now instead of VidCon
because like you're gonna be a dad
VidCon and oh yeah you guys think I want
to talk to nobody that's actually true
we are gonna be real we're gonna yeah
we're gonna be busy yeah get enjoy not
sleeping for like six months though
you're staying on yeah I can't even
imagine I didn't I don't know I still
can't really believe it little guy in
diapers and all that baby stuff I know
it I know it's it probably sounds stupid
anyone but like it starts to become so
surreal though that like there's a
little baby that's half me and half you
mm-hmm and it's like a full-grown baby
now I can feel when every movement you
can see it dude you can see because I
know I'm a like the same a bit of an
impact but when you first said that I
saw in your smile both this has its
hesitant hesitating worried and this
wonderment and you're like he's gonna
have this night person he's gonna be a
little bit you seem so happy and so
scared at the same time it was
fascinating to see that look because I'm
I don't know it's so crazy yeah I'm so
I'm so proud of you guys I'm so jealous
I never wanted kids but because you know
I grew up in an abusive home and I don't
know that I could be a good dad and I
just wasn't willing to risk it I you
know I was molested and beat up and all
this stuff and I I don't think I would I
know I would never do anything like that
to a kid but I don't know that I'm a
good person I don't know that the
depression and the anxiety is a good
environment to bring a child into but
you guys are killer I can you know I see
from what relationship I've seen on
YouTube but like you guys meeting you in
real life and seeing I think you guys
are gonna have a wonderful kid I think
you guys thank you for the coffee
I hope more like her than you yeah
unfortunately I feel like he's gonna
look more like I feel like if you find a
good relationship were you gonna be
happy with that person you can have it
right exactly I don't think that I have
anxiety too and you have issues and
everyone's got issues right right right
we have got a problem you figure it out
let's get shredder you know that's how
that's how I knew I wanted to be a
parent right right that shredder
I joke about killing myself are you and
what do you think of your dog's I mean
but here's the thing I mean it
it's not a joke okay now that said
that's a joke but bo burnham you you
interviewed bo right yes um I enjoyed
that episode it was awkward of points
but I enjoyed boazlin walk or near a
little awkward it's awkward a point I
don't really you way you weren't here it
was so awkward right right but he at one
point and this is how I remember it so
forgive me both you ever hear this and
I'm misremembering it but I remember at
some point I think on his website he
said he was born on this year and he's
going to die on this year and then it
was asked by a reporter why do you think
you're gonna die that year and I think
he said if I hope I'm not mister
remembering this misquoting the guy oh
that's the year that I've done the math
and that's the year than my dog will die
and that's the year I plan to kill
myself and I thought that was just a
dark joke at that point because I didn't
have a dog yet and now that I have my
dog and this dog it's the best dog in
the world I love still we literally know
yes here's the thing whoever thinks they
have the best dog in the world they're
right cuz all dogs are the best don't I
wrong I ever met a right dog you're
wrong but Sammy God loved him the best
thing my ex-wife ever did for me and she
literally saved my Walt life is she said
even though every time we ever talked
about sweating she's like and I'm taking
the dog cause he's my dog when we
finally split she's like you should keep
the dog and because she decided to do
that during the darkest points to
Christmas after the divorce no matter
how miserable I was furry little
bastards like this thing right here look
at this look at this be careful red it's
gonna make fun of you let them KITT lick
your face oh my god you're so gross
oh no but but little monsters like this
I made it through those darkest points
and that dog is so addicted to me now 24
hours a day we're physically in constant
just like when you stepped out just a
few minutes ago and shredder followed
you no matter where you're going
Sammy's exactly I literally leaned
forward in the chair and seems like what
we're going what are we doing he's the
most loyal dog and it's wild because
when I got him it was a shitty dog was
he he he grew up I guess with in a home
with three other animals and that made
him miserable and when he came to the
house he was pissing all over the place
he was [ __ ] all over the place if he
tried to pick him up he would bite you
he would run from you and we had to just
completely change this baby
but within six months I had him okay
playing in my arms I had him laying in
my arms eating treats in my lap and the
what a triumph right and so now when I'm
gone for five days he's just the most
depressed dog and I'm depressed without
him it really but when I'm at home we
were within physical contact 24 hours a
day I learned to take a bath that's the
only time he can't touch me so he's in a
he's laying next to the tub does that
we're dead he's laying next to me
touching me if I'm filming for YouTube
my dog 90% of the time he's laying on a
stool next to me with his butt touching
my leg
napping yeah unless he has to get up to
go out or something there so pure I say
I always say to Gila I wasn't sure about
I'm not a yeah he prefers to drink are
there angels they are truly angels on
this planet we don't deserve dogma and
I've you've seen Ricky Gervais is no
serious afterlife so much it's waiting
good get a new afterlife Oh his show I'm
sin but I will tell you that's how it
starts is his wife dies from cancer and
he's super depressed and he he wants to
kill himself basically but then the dog
comes in and looks at him like he's
hungry or something and he's like it's
so funny because I actually tweeted to
Ricky Gervais to tell him what he showed
in that show is almost exactly what I
experienced after my divorce because I
kind of turned into an [ __ ] you can
see clips of me being an [ __ ] on the
internet because I was being an ass on
there cuz I was hurt and I was miserable
and I'm suffering and I was depressed
and he didn't want to be there I don't
want to do anything and I was just so
unhappy and what he was going through
with the suicidal thoughts and then and
the ideology and I didn't use heroin or
anything like that but I I did some
really stupid self-destructive stuff
because I was just so unhappy
and to see him make it through that show
and I just gone through that entire
process and was about where the
character is at the end of that show I
was like that couldn't have been more
real like that if you haven't watched
that on Netflix you have to watch it did
you also think oh you did yeah I didn't
know but you watch that
very fast just like you watched
everything on Netflix it's like in one
day I tried to stretch it out to I was
like I want to watch one episode of that
because his other series on Netflix
Derek if you've seen that know it's he
plays like a mentally challenged
mentally challenged to do two works at
like an old folks home and you will cry
every episode with me yeah it's like
mentally challenged a missile yeah and
he does it really well it plays like a
mentally challenged dude car Lincoln
turns in the show right yeah and it's a
drama
it's a dramedy I would say because it is
funny it parts and definitely has some
comic relief but you will cry every
episode if you watch the video and you
don't write once that you are not a
human you are dead inside that guy
something else man he's a real
juggernaut yeah I live nothing but love
and respect for that dude I I would take
a bullet for that guy he's easily you
want a better comedian I think so man
he's it's not just he's a good comedian
but it's just that he's using his power
to tell very real stories no one else is
telling I wonder if you would ever be in
a situation and take a bullet probably
not that's why I say it right ever was
in that situation you're like a defeated
shakiness your hand and then someone
it's like slow motion and then you like
recall this conversation but you guys
have to remember I'm self-destructive
anyway I warned you and you're looking
for somebody stab me yeah every time you
meet someone say nice to meet you and
take a bullet for you yeah I'm the
bullet I'm the bull again
I'm fat I can take four or five men
through this this party you know I I saw
episode of cops where a fat guy got
stabbed and he was totally fine because
he there was so much fat you break it
didn't even come close to admitting his
life I thought I have a member I have a
memory one time being fatty I had a
vivid memory of that I was like wow
being fat saved this man's life hmm
and what I was useful yeah I wonder if I
wonder if there's more we haven't yet
thought of you float really well so if
you're really really hard to get to the
bottom of the water when I was like 400
pounds or so is it easy for you to lay
back and just be really
right so have you ever got like in the
ocean we wouldn't even it'll flight
jacket man really he's way for rescues
we like chillin till shark comes up and
bite you see you but you're so fat he's
just gonna take a little bit of you
right been feeling like I just want to
go in and pull know that I'm like oh
it's gonna be have you not done it are
you doing like I wanna okay can I really
probably you're gonna like natural
childbirth or like water birth or clear
water birth is like amazing what do you
think they're doing regular Hospital
epidural if your regular [ __ ] right you
have any pain or anything get into some
battery it's so useful because my back
hurts I'm so sorry have you heard of a
skydiving birth is that where you pull
the cord and then like jerks Redis the
hex crowning you jump out but the doctor
and you have about you know five minutes
or so so it it increases the intensity
and you just you really get it done cuz
you don't want to hit that ground you
don't hit that ground when the baby's
not out all the way or maybe you do
maybe maybe if you're in Texas and just
can't give an abortion any other way
alrighty what do you got for the rest of
LA um This Is It this is a the last
thing I wanted to do I did a universal
and walked off a mile and did all bunch
of rides I couldn't fit on every ride
but I'm fed almost and did you do the
Harry Potter I could not fit on but I
did have a butterbeer and Mountain Dew
can [ __ ] right off because that was
amazing that I had a butterbeer and I
was like oh my god this [ __ ] is so dirty
yeah I couldn't finish it but it was
like and it's just like a mega cream
soda right I had launched it like the
Three Broomsticks and then the the
studio tour which is the real reason I
was there I can about yeah and then did
the walking dead experience twice cuz
amazing it was terrifying because I
don't get what they've done was about
the walking dead the last three seasons
since like negan hit that one guy in the
head I'm just like done right but the
walking dead experience was terrifying
they love haunted houses man I'm coming
back for I think in October to come to
Knott's Scary Farm just just to do that
because I love that scary show well you
got to keep you got to get on Harry
Potter that's when you know right right
right
how do they measure you how do they
there so there's a little measurement a
little you know test seat or whatever
and she's like you're so close honey can
you just pull your stomach in I'm like
no because I could have probably pulled
my stomach in to fit the rest of the way
but they don't have to ride a ride like
that Yeah right
I think I would have I didn't had no
interest in on the wooden rollercoaster
I think I would have fit on that one yes
did him again yeah but I felt when
everything else wanted to do so that's
awesome the Simpson ride was really good
for such an old ride to I was like a
really awesome smart yeah but oh I do it
was like a car yeah
but Disney I was able to do I did Disney
in December um took my friend
mcjuggernuggets and Adam the whoo he's a
great creator if you don't know I don't
look him up on YouTube he's amazing
he literally does Disneyland for a
living that's literally a job because
the theme parks for a job it's amazing
well so is that YouTube he just
literally goes in films like rides and
films like doesn't like a new Shaq opens
it at Universal he goes in films the
experience and then shares it with
everybody
he's been doing it for like how do you
not run out of content because there's
always something changing at Disneyland
always something and he gets a lot of
views it's enough I mean he gets like 25
30,000 views per video and then
eventually like everyone's wrong to get
a viral is too much viral videos he went
into the backstage of F cought Center
like where stuff was shut down and
filmed once and then another time he
went to Universal Studios Florida and
the old Nickelodeon soundstage he filmed
the urban decay of the old Nickelodeon
soundstage and solves like some of the
old stuff were like Ren and Stimpy are
still on the wall and those videos got
millions of millions of views and really
made his name but so that's what he does
for a living he goes to theme parks and
explores the country and films kölsch it
and it was love I watched every episode
I had for three years
um though we went to Disney and I rode
my first roller coaster since I was
fifteen
it was doing credit coaster I wrote them
all the in credit credit coasters the
only that one item lights yeah it was
Tara one that one is really and it was
in that was the first experience right
that was actually it was amazing yeah I
have an anxiety
so I mostly just screamed the whole time
cuz I lost complete control yeah and
then we did both parks we did distant
California the only thing I regret doing
was the guardians of Galaxy ride [ __ ]
whoever engineered that love that I
hated your man tits
choking you as you okay that's the
difference right
I literally literally had my gut wrap
around my head like I needed to be cut
out that's how bad it was
look at actual footage or an Adam's you
know me doing the all these rights and
when we were doing the guardians of the
galaxy one you can already see my tits
left I know it's because it's you fall
faster than gravity it's yeah faster
than gravity yeah
that's insane right that's the only one
I regret but Space Mountain was also a
hell of an experience because it's a
dark roller don't like the dark and I
don't like roller coaster so I I did use
my my pain reliever to get through
VidCon that day and I was probably a
little little buzzed by the time we got
the Space Mountain and I'm glad I was on
it because I passed out on Space
Mountain like in the queue I passed out
at one point and I played it off like I
was just setting down I knew that I
passed out right but like are you sure
yeah enough from like exhaustion
sidewalk like seven and half miles that
day right like if my body wasn't ready
for example imagine yeah we gotta get
you like a disney season past and just
get you out there hell yeah right like
or even just moving to a city because
the walk i like this morning i got up
and walked three and a half lakhs just
for fun right now who cares right like I
actually have places you know yeah makes
exactly I was in New York man I was
walking so much yeah because it's just
it's naturals party do you ever miss New
York um not really
I like LA a lot I like I mean New York's
really fun to visit but overall I think
LA's is such a fantastic place I really
like it because John was always the New
York boy right you know and then he's
moved to the edge of New York well he's
in New Jersey now okay John right John
so funny he goes he he'll be he's the
New York boy and then all the sudden one
day he's like I hate New York right now
that may be always of a Newark and he's
like I never said that
no but he's in New York he's in New
Jersey
he loves it she still loves it my kids
he's I think I need to watch more case
maybe
well I know he didn't tell me not to say
anything
Yeah right he told me he's moving LA
yeah that's cool man but John Johnson to
him great
he's [ __ ] killed I know that I'm
Rooney for like three videos up in the
last month Dolph I know he's out he's
out uploading me not that that's a feed
these days but I mean and plus I'm like
your videos are good I really like know
what's coming I love what you've been
uploading but mine yeah yeah I was I was
making the joke that Jon's countenance
better than yours yeah but it's not a
joke so no it's not no he put so much
work into I the one time I got to hang
out with John or life wait was it a joke
no it's not at all John's content it's
amazing it's like better than mine it's
better than anybody's do know but it's
usually it's better than [ __ ] anybody
seriously like one time I talked to John
the one time I thought your honor hung
out with him at VidCon and it's like
buddy I want to quit YouTube and like
yukia says that every night it goes it's
just so hard and I know it doesn't have
to be hard John you make it hard on
yourself because every video has to be
better than the last video and we know
it doesn't
I would watch you complain about Donkey
Kong in your bedroom again just make
that please make that thank know there
has to be good in capably is neurotic
actually neuroses
right yeah I feel bad for the guy but
know her because it's the videos or oh
well better than last I think what he
needed is a really good team support
system what she has he's in a really
healthy relationship with a really great
girl
yeah and he's just got everything great
and he seems like mentally he's in a
good place he's got a good team around
him and so I think he's just a healthier
place and to be creative you know I'm
trying to build now for myself right I
don't think I'll ever meet the girl I've
given up on that but I've got like I
hired my first uh I hired my team to do
my little crappy podcast and a little
gaming podcast nobody listens to I was
really doing that to try to build their
careers and then hired my roommate who
was working custodial at the you know
the hyper building and doing mowing
lawns and crap hired him on as my PA and
and now I have like an actual team and
and then we're I'm gearing up to hire to
do this story fire creation stuff the
content there with Francis to film in
that gaming store I bought and like get
some actual actors to make an actual
narrative to help actual story and yeah
I feel like really creative for the
first time in a while and I felt like
I'm sticking to my creative integrity
and and yeah I'm gonna like really good
place not that I think if most people
were in the place of it right now they
would be like wow it's hard being you
you're suicidal and miserable and I'm
like yes but it's also the best I've
ever been this is the happiest I've ever
been
including the whole time I was married
including my first year of upper-bound
including yeah I just I don't know I
feel like I feel like I'm taking on the
world well let's keep it going
you know yeah let's keep that predict
turi going let's see you in a year let's
get you on that Harry Potter ride oh
yeah and I'm always looking forward to
Boogie's next visit oh yeah well I'll
see you in exactly one year yeah one
year yeah and I'll have a one-year-old
shave I know that's right he doesn't
exist yet but he will next year mm-hmm
it's wild man you made life yeah I know
and that life is going to affect the
world do you think about that right
let's so what we're all doing as
creators right we're trying to affect
the world a little bit either it's just
entertain people to make them happier or
whatever but you're putting real life in
the world that life could cure cancer
one day it's not design now he's gonna
be great he's gonna be a cool dude but
if he's anything like I mean if he's
like me he's not curing cancer he might
get really good at fortnight three now
we're talking now we've got expectations
in the right place now it's not like Pro
but like pretty good right like pretty
good yeah a guy win like one oh yeah
yeah my dream is to get rich enough so
that he just will never have to work and
he can play for tonight all day a real
trust on baby
right you ever see a key and peele has a
sketch about Will Smith's son Jaden no
all right and it's like super funny
sketching is one of my favorites but
Jaden is like reading a script right and
he's like trying to relate to this
I was talking to this agent in this
agents like yeah so this this he's plays
basketball and it goes right so where
does he play the basketball he's like
outside it's like in the hallway and
he's like no no outside he's like in the
garage he's like no no outside well what
is outside outside is that area like
when you get into your limo it's the
stuff you drive through and he's like oh
why would you play ball out there this
is like one of those like you imagine
raising the key that's so completely
desensitized as Jane Smith as to what
reality like her first theater that's
what I want for my dog yeah yeah that's
kind of the joy about dogs you can spoil
them like you can and I do so bad like
in order to find because he was addicted
to human food when we got him and he was
underweight because they wouldn't feed
him very often he so I had to buy one of
every treat mmm that existed on Amazon
to find three that he liked yeah and now
to feed him those three he only eats
part of them there's this one called
goofballs in it's a white rawhide ball
but there's a little red chicken script
that runs through it
he'll piece out the chicken strip and
then throw away the rawhide they come
out so like a buck a ball so he's even
like for a day yeah I'm spending four
bucks a day on one of the treats but who
gives a [ __ ]
yeah he's my dog he did I will starve
before that dog will do without a a
goofball yeah we got to get him that we
gotta get goofballs stat mm-hmm all
right we'll see you in a year Q ma'am we
wish you well we wish you all the best
we wish you a happy 'no sand joy stay
out of the comment saying yourself
I'm not even checking Twitter for the
layout Leon just do it just do it do a
check and then give yourself a week and
after the week B just check in with
yourself
see how you're doing here's what I will
say let me close with this okay if
anything I have said in this podcast has
been stupid if anything I've said on the
Internet has been stupid
I won't even though I have nothing but
the best of intentions the only thing I
want is for the people listening right
now to have love and prosperity and and
find some happiness in their life and if
you're unhappy with me screw me it's
ignore me forget I exist
and go find something that makes you
happy man don't spend your time tearing
me down spend your time building
yourself up that's all I've ever tried
to do for me I was trying to never tear
anybody down Tim Sweeney maybe
from time to time but for the most part
I'm just trying to build my life up
please let me do that and and why don't
you guys go do that for yourselves right
I get it
I suck sometimes I've really screwed up
and I've tried to make up for it I'm
trying to be a better person I'm trying
to put positivity in the world and I'm
trying to help people whether it's get
their teeth done or come play in my game
store or whatever man and and I hope you
choose to do the same put the same
effort you would put into tearing me or
Ethan or ela or little teddy or shredder
down little teddy yeah you know I've
been in the world people are sitting on
hell write it use that same effort to
build your life out and and let's make
this place a better place man hey let's
make the for door yeah
great again yeah thank you for that
beautiful I already hear you troll ass
[ __ ] [ __ ] hater ass
[ __ ] you cooks get a [ __ ] life
in other words right and I will not get
I do you a [ __ ] losers yes
that's how I feel to get a life all
right guys hope you have a terrific
weekend thank you as always for watching
we love and appreciate you h3 army we're
going to war every episode here on the
h3 pot yes we are going to war thanks
for watching I love you very much and
I'll speak with you again soon sons of
[ __ ]
you [ __ ] boxing [ __ ] get off already
go find a girl yeah
[Music]